oh
[Musique]
4e étage
andré commandes à olivia
[Musique]
toujours dans la dans le camp paysagiste
atteignant
oui
sur des sorties dans l'est
en appelant au sort
ça tout seul
ternat
ça va bon ça va très bien je suis avec
cambrai bien celui-là sur le premier non
non non elles sont arrivées du fait
qu'en même temps avant
c'est toi allez on avance comme des
filles bien petite surprise arrive à
rêver équipe est que ces drones
alors la mienne saint germain des prés
ac c'est comme se disent que vous êtes
mais j'attends tout le monde soit
l'arbre énorme et oued turquie et qu'il
est là parce qu'andré veille la
délicatesse de ne pas rapporter je suis
bien sûr et heureusement qu'il ya des
bons copains comment ça va mais ça va
pas mal quand on était à cyril putman
jean bricmont final explique janet qui a
survécu mais d'alcool sur les noms que
je viens en de l'eau minérale s'il vous
plaît vous bien donner du jus de fruits
si tu veux ça va bien et est où là aux
etats unis
là j'arrive des états unis face à l'aube
à vous ensuite on fait petite aventure
continue comme des fous et voilà ils ont
tendance à lâcher un peu plus fou ça oui
les gens sont sensibles au fait qu'en
effet un européen et en particulier un
français se soit appuyé le boulot quoi
il menace est bizarre alors est-il libre
qui l'imaginent bouche à oreille avec le
croit trois cas déjà le principe s'est
reconverti en vérité l'histoire et je me
rappelle quand j'ai annoncé à olivier
nora il ya un an et demi que j'allais
consacré un livre à lasbordes daniel
peur olivier qui est un très bon
observateur des états unis m'a tout de
suite dit coûté faites le si vous voulez
ce sera sûrement pas mal mais faites
attention il y aura avant la parution de
votre livre 18 livres écrits par des
journalistes américains sur le même
sujet enfin sachez le très bien joué
j'ai fait de livres persuadés qu'ils
auraient déjà il est finalement très
intéressants qui pourraient vraies
questions sur la manière dont les
américains
les français sont incapables de parler
de leur histoire a eu donc peut-être les
américains c'est pareil parce qu'on
regarde le livre de baek bd oui mais
sony qui répondront cette saison n'y a
pas eu un livre c'est lui qui raconte
daniel peur en prison tandis que c'est
vrai mais en même temps
thierry en même temps qu empirer je me
rappelle à la tienne avec avec une eau
minérale grands crus enchères christie
bernard henri lévy bonsoir voir tu
publies le numéro un d'une revue qui
s'appelle la règle du jeu je suis pas
seul dans cette histoire ouais vous êtes
un certain nombre d années via scarpetta
liant event un comité à l'action qui
dirige cette revue avec moi alors
l'ambition de la règle du jeu c'est de
penser le post communisme parce qu'au
delà d'un autre ou la d'écoulement d'un
d'un régime c'est une civilisation qui
meurt d'une certaine façon et donc non
pas de combler le vide - l'explorer quoi
c'est ça oui moi je crois qu'on est en
train de on est en train de sortir du
communisme et que des sorties à des
bonnes sorties et des mauvaises sorties
il ya des vrais sortie il ya des fausses
sorties type de mauvaises sorties par
exemple ce serait un déferlement de
xénophobie de tribalisme good racisme
comme on voit dans la sambre de pays de
l'est
et comme on voit même en france bonne
sortie ce serait la démocratie le
libéral il une vraie culture que ce
volet dit moi je suis un écrivain qui
comme tony il ya un truc qui m'a
beaucoup plu il ya un regret dans ce que
tu écris en ce moment pour l'empiré
austro hongrois
sans être un mois je ne suis pas je suis
pas royaliste mais je crois néanmoins
que
will empire austro hongrois avait le
mérite de d'établir une espèce de transe
en danse de la citoyenneté qui qui
permettait d'économiser tout un tas de
petites saloperies tribales racistes et
xénophobes avant 14
avant on était certes croates serbes
polonais ce slovaque était grave mais on
était en plus autre chose qui était
citoyenne l' empire austro-hongrois
sinon tu vois une île et je le regrette
d'emploi votre is oui mais c'est pas
tellement qu'il regrette c'est que je
crois que tous les gens tous les gens
bien de ces pays là vaclav havel en
tchécoslovaquie georgie conrad en
hongrie tous les vrais démocrates des
pays de l'est regrette ce temps là oui
ils disent tous que enfin ils
s'orientent vers des solutions de
fédérations d'associations d'état qui
ressembleront d'une certaine manière à
ce qu est l empire austro-hongrois
je crois que c'est là c'est la nostalgie
majeur d'une bonne nouvelle alors en
quoi la règle du jeu
c'est paisible ça me plaît en quoi la
règle du jeu peut aider tous ces pays de
l'est à faire une bonne sortie du
communisme et doute la règle du jeu
les intellectuels servent pas à
grand-chose la littérature lancement
ça n'est rien d'autre que la littérature
je crois néanmoins qu'il ya une bataille
d'idées en ce moment dans les pays de
l'est une bataille idéologique entre
entre deux il ya deux lignes ou si tu
préfères 2 europe qui sont en train de
se combattre dans une espèce de corps à
corps qui est je crois très dur l'un de
mes interlocuteurs en pologne qui est
adam michnik me parlait même d'une d'une
énorme affaire dreyfus à l'échelle de
l'ensemble de l'europe et qui dit
bataille d'idées dit rôle des idées je
crois que les producteurs d'idées les
gens qui font métier de penser
peuvent essayer de peser dans le bon
sens moi je
je pense par exemple que en pologne ou
en hongrie où il ya une vraie bataille
entre les entre les cosmopolites et les
autres on peut renforcer les
cosmopolites on peut leur apporter
d'abord notre amitié mais enfin une
belle jambe
accessoirement le soutien moral
désormais un peu plus un peu organisés
les fameuses la règle du jeu ira
il ira on dit par exemple irradie
d'appel on fera des choses avec alors
sortir du communisme et puis deuxième
ambition de la règle du jeu le droit de
l'hommisme ça suffit plus aujourd'hui
face aux enjeux et par quoi le remplacer
alors ce droit de l'hommisme qui était
devenu quand même le nec plus ultra de
la pensée française depuis une dizaine
d'années enfin ça suffit plus ça veut
dire ça veut dire en effet que c'est un
peu court je crois qu'on peut pas
répondre
il ya des problèmes énormes qui se pose
aujourd'hui en europe de l'est mais
aussi aussi en français et parce que on
donne beaucoup leçon aux européens de
l'aisne faudrait qu l'antenne vers une
revue pour la france dans les pays
froids qu'il suffit pas d'ânonner droits
de l'homme droits de l'homme droits de
l'homme qu'est ce qu'il faut penser à
bon si je le serai pas une revue c'est
pour trouver et vous trouvez pas si je
fais une revue c'est parce que je pense
que ça prendra du temps
ouais et une revue c'est quelque chose
qui s'installe dans la durée
j'espère que tu le sais c'est ce que tu
veux voilà alors tu as dit la fonction
des intellectuels c'est de produire du
complexe c'est pas de simplifier ses de
complexifier alors rendez vous
contrairement à ce qu'on croit donc
voilà je vais poser des questions
simples et j'espère que tu vas pas trop
complexifier
[Musique]
ainsi je t'ai dit mao tsé toung qu'est
ce que tu me dis je dîne très très
vieille histoire
ouais un peu de un peu de ma jeunesse et
en même temps une histoire terminée ou
une autre elle est ma aux maoïstes ont
pensé quoi il ya deux choses il ya
d'abord les gens qui étaient des
militants mao qui militait au sein d'une
organisation qui appelle à gauche
prolétarienne devons ça j'en ai jamais
été bon et j'en demeure comme julie
comme jambes et comme lardreau d'autres
étaient de l'été d'un gauche
prolétarienne c'était pas mon front de
gauche prg et moi j'ai jamais été là
dedans en revanche je crois oui un peu
quand j'avais 17 18 et 20 ans j'étais
dans cette mouvance là je pensais un peu
comme ça mais ça quand l'arrière par une
loi ça me parait de dix neuvième siècle
d'accord mais par l'ensemble c'est pas
ça consistait en quoi ça consistait à
croire qu'on pouvait changer l'homme or
ce qu'il avait de plus profond c'était
le slogan de l'époque ça consistait à
croire qu'on pouvait casser en deux
l'histoire du monde
c'est ce que disait mao en chine et
c'est ce que nous répétions oui si vous
pensez en effet qu'on pouvait enfin les
mao pensait qu'il pouvait en finir avec
avec l'histoire du malheur avec
l'histoire de là avec la mort avec la
mort non mac l'histoire du malheur en
tournée le fait peut-être trompé à
l'époque
depuis chaque fois que tu a émis des
idées tu t'es pas dit peut-être que je
suis encore en train de me tromper je me
le dis tout le temps moi je fais partie
des gens qui disent même lorsque j'ai
l'air automatique que péremptoire etc
je fais partie des gens qui se disent
oui bien sûr je pourrais me tromper
gorbatchev
ça c'est pas le visage avec ça ça c'est
mal dans ce qui m'agace avec gorbatchev
c'est cette espèce de
deux reflex midinettes quand un peu les
journalistes énormément les accidents
les gorilles maniable c'est autre chose
c'est une entreprise très tout à fait
étrange assez atypique unique me
semble-t-il dans l'histoire des 70
dernières années qui est de sortir du
communisme tout temps tout en conservant
deux parties il faut des détroits je
crois qu'il faut l'aider oui je crois
qu'il faut l'aider mais pas à n'importe
quel prix
je les pays baltes par exemple ils sont
pas d'accord il vient pas en avant comme
après il s'agit pas de donner on a
suffisamment donné de blanc seing à
d'autres on va pas en devient à
gorbatchev bien sûr arafat à rafah
tarrafal jeu
c'est quelqu'un qui sait quelqu'un pour
lequel j'ai pas une passion le soyons
francs c'est quelqu'un qui est pas
seulement pour les raisons que tu
pourrais croire aux coûts pourrait
croire c'est quelqu'un qui a soutenu à
l'époque l'intervention russe en
afghanistan c'est quelqu'un qui a
soutenu jaruszalski à la pire époque
c'est quelqu'un qui est à peu près
toujours pris de maux des partis dans
les grandes affaires du monde
cela dit moi je suis de ceux qui depuis
des années et des années jeudi en israël
même pense qu'il faut négocier riscle
pour négocier que ses ennemis tous ses
conseillers quand tu vois les drapeaux
israéliens à la manifestation
pour carpentras tu penses quoi toi je
pense que c'est très con le pen le pen
pour moi je pour moi c'est un voyou ou
un tortionnaire et un fasciste et puis
c'est tout tu crois qu'il faut le rendre
inéligible
non je crois pas qu'il faut leur en
damier je pense qu'il faut le rendre
infréquentable et ce qui est différent
de nous jean marie domenach
ah ça c'est vraiment con pas jean marie
doré que c'est une histoire assez
tristes parce que c'est quelqu'un qui a
pas été mal
cap a été mal dans la résistance qui m
était bien enfin c'est un vraie
résistance et c'est quelqu'un qui est en
train de très belles tournées qui
d'année dernière il ya eu un vrai
passage à l'acte antisémite cette
manière de se croire persécutés
persécuté par les juifs c'est à peu près
ça par des intellectuels juifs non il a
fait une espèce de petit délire comme ça
sur la place publique expliquant que des
gens comme visuel moi je crois que
j'étais dans le fourgon les dividendes
bon c'est ignoble et c'est surtout c'est
surtout triste parce que cette c'est en
même temps c'est probablement pas un
intellectuel n'est qu'effet l'idéologie
française
et puis que tu dis finalement le
pétainisme c'est giscard en haut que lui
chamba et puis quelques années après tu
dis le socialisme à la française c'est
le pétainisme bien ça veut dire que bon
la droite était tennis la gauche et
pétainiste
est-ce que tu suscites pas chez des gens
comme domenach ils ne l'aiment d'une
certaine façon parce que ils ont ils ont
pas envie d'être dans le sac là parce
qu'ils étaient résistants j'ai jamais
dis les choses tout à fait comme tu
viens de l'est les dix régions avec un
peu de rapidité
non j'ai j'ai dit en effet qu'il y avait
il y avait beaucoup de pétainisme en
france et qui en avaient souvent dans
des endroits qu'on ne soupçonnait pas
jma en effet qu'elle dit est émise ma
gauche faurisson faurisson moi j'ai pour
règle de ne pas prononcer son nom je
viens d'enfreindre la règle parce que je
crois que c'est à peu près aussi
faurisson sait même pas
comment te dire c'est à peu près aussi
absurde c'est à peu près aussi
méprisables que un géographe qui dirait
la mer méditerranée n'existe pas mais
métaphysicien qui dirait la priory la
relativité je m'assieds mais s'il ya
quelqu'un qui arrive en des andes à
paulhan n'a jamais existé par exemple au
bout de deux minutes le débat est clos
donc pourquoi pas accepter le débat si
les clés au bout de deux minutes parce
que probablement les gens qui ont pour
métier d'organiser les débats de l'e de
les commenter
on sur cette question là où onze de
perversité moi je crois que la sphère
faurisson a commencé à se poser le jour
où un journal a publié face à face dans
une grande et belle page un article de
faurisson et un article d'un anti
faurisson comme si les deux thèses ce
ballet et là je crois que le mal était
fait jean-edern hallier
jean est un délit je dirais que c'est
maurice axe sans talent sans judaïsme
vraiment pour nous sans la collaboration
et ce temps-là l'occupation à nourrice
qui du reste grâce maurice axes x man où
s'est perdue de vue
ouais je les ai perdus patrick besson
patrick besson que je connais pas bien
j'avais lu un livre j'ai lu un livre de
lui qui était le livre aussi librement
sur pouchkine que j'avais trouvé que
j'avais tout est bien bourbon par
exemple on lui sait pas rancunier
finalement vous avez ça dépend qui denis
tillinac
c'est là c'est la corrèze ou et dénis
oui moi je moi je préfère encore la
zambèze au corps le zambèze à l'accord
ouais vraiment à lui morgan sportès je
sais pas qui fait si c'était je ne sais
pas si c'est parce que j'ai jamais
jamais lui céder jamais musique ni celui
là lui détient et d amour
non mais tu sais tu n'as pas confiance
les gens sont terribles marc edouard
nabe ont marqué dans ma vie j'ai lu un
de ses livres etc qui s'appelait au
régal des vermines
et ça c'est un cap du visage moi je
pense que le personnage est à comment te
dire sans être
sans être accusé des territoires chaud
je crois qu'il ya des choses qui sont
infâmes dans dans ce livre est
insupportable cela dit il n'est pas
exclu que ce soir écrivent il n'est pas
exclu que ce soit à l'écrivain bernard
henri lévy alors je dirais quoi qui
étaient là en face et qu'ils doivent
parler de lui je dirais que c'est un
écrivain
ouais sinon il ya du monde faire quoi
faire pour exister
alain delon et béni les lycées fort bon
maintenant c'était c'était tout le pari
de gilles dans ce premier numéro
mais la règle du jeu ça s'est arrêté un
moment non ça a commencé en 89
après on dit que parce que on se colle
toujours à ce grand événement à la chute
du mur de berlin
bon dum et puis ça s'est arrêté dix ans
après un peu moins de rui dix ans après
quand tu avais jamais comme ça commence
à aller mieux
ouais mais plus maintenant que ça va
moins bien mais ça repart pas que ça va
moins bien pour le monde au début
pourquoi vous l'avez fait cette rue mais
et l égard du volcan pour la région non
non non non pour la raison que disent
ils c'est à dire c'est vraiment là la
décision crée la règle du jeu c'était le
lendemain la nuit de la chute du mur de
berlin
on s'est retrouvé jean paul gilles ne
soit pas vouloir écouter violent et nous
on a décidé on s'est dit bah nouveau
monde commence ça va pas se passer
forcément comme un comme nous à les
draws y aura des convulsions des
crispations des drames des machins des
nationalismes qui vont venir des guerres
qui éclateront dans les balkans le
réveil des nations comme disait notre
ami
notre ami mac et voilà il faut essayer
de penser ça à partir du régime y allait
avoir des guerres en europe voilà
puisque avant il n'y avait pas de
dimanche de l'histoire il y avait des
optimistes parmi nous qui disait à
partir de la chute du mur en maintenant
à part sa tâche est dure fin de
l'histoire démocratie général
tous ces pays libéré de la beauce
communistes etc vont se retrouver dans
la démocratie miraculeuse messianisme
démocratique
c'était d'ailleurs les plus pessimistes
d'entre nous qui croyaient à cet
optimisme historique à 7 ans vota
position jean paul jammes attendait
d'enfants c'est terminé il ne se passera
plus rien etc
et il y avait ceux comme gilles ou moi
qui disent non pas du tout 7la la fin de
l'affrontement entre communisme et
démocratie veut dire la relance d'autres
choses
on va voir apparaître des horreurs d d d
d espèce de truc bizarre des nationaux
communisme etc
et l'histoire se remettra en mouvement
pour le pire et c'est pour penser ce
pire qu'on a eu on s'est dit on va créer
ce machin
le pire c'est un peu calmé même un autre
pire est arrivé donc la revue c'est
d'arrêter
et puis comme tu es sans doute au
courant le drive
ouais et l'arrivée de redémare c'est
comme ça il ya des revues qui démarre
sur dos le jeu le 9 novembre au soir au
quai qui est de la date la plus
incroyable de l'histoire du 20e siècle
le 9 novembre qui est la chute du mur
c'est aussi la leur qui la nuit de
cristal du cristal à bord de deux beaux
et qui est à nuit qui attendait la chute
du mur la nuit cristal et le jour du
premier putsch d'hitler là le pouls de
la brasse les mixer le 9 novembre ce qui
a fait dire d'ailleurs aux observateurs
les plus paranoïaques de la criminologie
officielle de la fin du xxème siècle que
c'était là bien la preuve que c'est le
kgb qui avait provoqué la chute du mur
les gens se sont dits pour que ça soit
tombé c'est ce jour-là rahman en plus
c'est une dallas forcément une intention
maligne il est longue date allemande
réfléchissement repris le pouvoir les
conquêtes
voici bhl la dame
[Applaudissements]
comment ça va ça va mais j'étais mort de
rire on va pas se marrer l'ain alors la
passe et moins possible de sarre comme
ça d une chance je vous le recommande
ceci étant vous avez une phrase sur
sarthe dans votre bouquin à vous dites
comme quoi le génie ne vaccinent pas
contre le gâtisme oui j'ai des dernières
années qui sont un peu tristes me
reconnaissez que que le public est
brillant mais au moins non mais ce qu'a
lancé avec ça c'est qu'il ya un nom
c'était quand même l'écrivain le plus
ringard du monde jean paul sa personne
n'aurait osé parler de jean paul sartre
il ya un an
vous écrivez un livre sur sartre et
maintenant il fait la couverture des
magazines
il se revend les chemins de la liberté
se vend mais faire une pub pour la poste
bientôt pourquoi là écoutez je crois
qu'il je crois qu'il le méritait surtout
je crois que là l'état que vous décrivez
était très injuste oui c'était un très
grand écrivain et il était il était un
peu mou deal et au purgatoire donc en
effet je suis assez content et fier vous
avez montré non mais je sais mais j'ai
vu plein de trucs mais le couple est
magnifié en couple avec le castor
c'est fascinant louisbourg et j'aime
bien le couple aussi j'aime bien le
couple via les turbans de simone joli
saut plan sexuel c'est quelque chose à
damas entre simone et sartre également
non sartre à sartre avec les autres
femmes religieux à trois et est assez
étrange puisque l'idée c'était ça
c'était quand même des espèces de
liaisons dangereuses
version moderne ou sartre alors le truc
du couple s'était que sartre prenait son
pied quand il racontait aux castors ce
qu'il avait fait avec les autres et ça
donnait des lettres absolument
extravagantes d'une crudité assez
extrêmes
c'est une femme libérée le prenez bien
elle le prenait assez bien en tant que
femme libérée et en tant que femme
amoureuse parce que je crois qu'elle
était quand même assez folle de lui elle
n'avait pas le choix parce que s'il
avait joué la petite bourgeoisie
l'ordinateur t'es gentil tu viens
d'écrire le deuxième sexe ne pouvait pas
elle pouvait pas lui faire de scène en
même temps alors vous avez pris savent
pourquoi parce que celle inverse de vous
au départ oui parce que celle inverse de
moi et puis parce que c'était ça je les
dis souvent parce que c'était là la
meilleure manière de raconter le xxème
siècle quoi de le tirer là l'addition de
faire le bilan du siècle voilà je
voulais savoir dans quel état on sortait
du 20e siècle
il est extrêmement adulé et ail et aussi
un peu comme vous n'en aurez plus que
moi plus adulées d'abord et surtout plus
aïgue mais ça a tendance à s'arranger
malheureuse et plus il ya de choses que
j'avais pas compris jusqu'à présent et
en lisant le livre de bernard henri lévy
il aimait mieux approcher
c'est que c'était loin d'être un ipod un
aplomb et ils tombaient toutes les
femmes mais c'est souvent comme ça
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
il y avait quand même c'est tout voir de
sélection des oeuvres magnifiques savez
c'était le c'était le coup de socrate
c'est que c'était là la laideur de
madness france il ya des leaders comme
ça qui sont des fraudes les deux des
leaders séduisant que sartre avait une
laideur magnifique puis laideur qui
s'était fabriqué sartre est un des
auteurs présumés du fameux mot vous
savez à partir de 40 ans dans la gueule
qu'on mérite et il s'était fabriqué à 7
ce visage
bizarre vous aurez plus regardée mais me
plaît beaucoup plus grosse bouche moi
parce que j'ai eu une petite alors moi
je le trouve beau mais bon j'étais
dégoûté mais les vrais savent rien
l'autre bout alors qu'elle savait on
sentira pas du tout on dit de jacques
brel qu'il est laid je trouve très beau
on dit de gainsbourg qu'il était laid je
trouve très beau voilà je je je
comprends pas moi pour moi c'est des
gens beaux mais par les valeurs de la
télévision avec valérie lemercier qui
nous disait qu'elle préférait jouer 500
fois un spectacle sur scène que faire
une émission de télé vous vous dites la
télé ça a été longtemps follement
amusant j'étais un peu à la télé comme
devant un flipper et le flipper c'était
le monde puis peut-être que j'ai vieilli
mais maintenant ça m'amuse - c'est vrai
mais ça vous amuse et bien ce soir c'est
bien à cause de vous c'est sympa et
michèle bernier bouvard c'est vous qui
me fait rire j'ai été mis en condition
de glisse c'est vrai que mes biden que
vous avez pu vous chemise comme il ya 25
ans quand la télévision que parce que
vous ayez cher maintenant c'est fini
parce que quand vous avez vu le chemise
blanche ouverte échancrée font plus et
des enfants non plus ces procès pour
vous imitez manger je me suis mis un
ardisson reçoit alors d'islande et
histoire de vous déstabiliser invités
dites moi vous êtes conseiller
littéraire chez grasset entre autres
fonctions vous pensez quoi de la sphère
chazal attendait d'abord je vais
expliquer nos habitués spectateurs vous
connaissez la sphère chazal pourrait
laisser vous veillez bien à travers et
donc les rives résumé de la nasa
claire chazal écrit un livre en premier
livre qui s'appelait l'institutrice et
un second livre qui s'appelle à quoi bon
de souffrir donc les gens du journal
voici la réaction du jeune voici appris
le livre l'institutrice la retaper la
machine en changeant les noms et
l'envoyer à tout un tas d'éditeur à
paris qui ont tous selon les éditeurs du
bookcamp l'éditeur du bouquin en
changeant non évidemment les premiers
claire chazal ils ont mis un autre nom
et le livre a été refusé par tous les
partis ou les éditeurs de paris même par
plon donc qui est l'éditeur de claire
chazal
vous en pensez quoi vous de ça oui je
pense que c'est sûr que si ça je veux
bien rire mais ça n'a pas grand sens
parce qu'on compte quand des gens ont
fait le même push à marguerite duras ça
a été pareil quand on a envoyé à tous
les éditeurs de paris un livre de
marguerite duras en le nom de l'auteur
tous les éditeurs l'ont refusé oui trop
mais ça ne veut rien dit et pensé que
j'étais en plus que l'idée de voix si
c'était quoi c'était dire chazal ne
mérite d'être publié que parce qu'elle
présente le journal de 20h pour il est
arrivé la même chose à marguerite duras
camp romain gary publie des livres tout
le monde à jaar personne ne s'en rend
compte il ya des phrases entières des
paragraphes qui sont pompés de ses
anciens livres personne ne le voit quand
des plaisantins la fin des années
quarante puis bien phu rimbaud tout le
monde croit que c'est un vrai rimbaud
s'offre andré breton qui était le seul à
des voix la supercherie
donc ces trucs là c'est vieux comme la
littérature jeudi passé les ja rule art
très drôle mais ça ne signifie rien
c'est grave pour les éditeurs c'est pas
grave pour claire chazal ce à dire que
les éditeurs faisant état ne disent pas
les manuscrits si l'on voit ça veut dire
d'abord qu'il n'est pas apte à les
regarder l'histoire renaud camus
fayard publie un livre de renaud camus
avec des pages d'un antisémitisme tels
qu'ils jugent bond à tort ou à raison de
le retirer de la vente
il n'était pas versée ils l'ont pas lu
donc en effet on va pas découvrir que
les éditeurs font pas toujours très bien
leur métier
les éditeurs il leur arrive de ne pas
lire les bouquins ça c'est vrai
maintenant l'autre leçon également c'est
que
dans l'art la littérature ou dans ce qui
ressemble il faudrait il faudrait
plusieurs noms faudrait évidemment tous
appellent livre il faudra inventer
d'autres non il faudrait dire il a des
livres il ya des laveries liadé je ne
sais pas mais penser qu'on est un livre
de claire chazal sur des contrôles dans
ce que sinon c'est du très c'était pas
mal monde parce que l'institutrice était
pas si mal justement c'est là où tout ça
est assez injuste et où cette façon en
gros ce qui m'énerve c'est que cette
façon que tout le monde allait lui
tomber dessus
ouais toute la critique littéraire au
grand complet en gants blancs avec
armure et où il ya quelque chose d'un
peu désagréable faut dire aussi un peu
puisqu'on est pour qu'on est sur claire
chazal dans le nouveau livre qu'elle a
publiés qui s'appelle à quoi bon
souffrir le héros il change de nom au
cours du livre tiers qui s'appelle
thierry un moment et pierre quelques
pages plus loin
soit c'est un effet et c'est une femme
moderne kate en effet littéraire ça
m'étonnerait soit c'est à dire que je
suis là non plus l'éditeur n'a pas lui
en tout cas
écoutez ça peut s'appliquer la phase
aller faire un roman
c'est à la fois bénéficier d'un préjugé
favorable c'est évident et puis c'est à
la fois quand même se met dans le
collimateur et prendre le risque tout le
monde lui tombe dessus ce qui vient de
lui arriver
bernard henri lévy alors on vous connaît
bien vous connais pas bien je me suis
penché un petit peu sur votre parcours
vous êtes née en 1948 en algérie à béni
saf votre famille c'était des
pieds-noirs fortunés il faisait quoi
mon père était là était un industriel
voilà vous êtes retourné là-bas et ça
vous a pas ému finalement non je n'ai
jamais vécu en algérie et j'y suis allé
pour la première fois à 40 ans ouais et
c'est vrai que ça m'a est oui c'est vrai
que l'idée c'était ça dans comédie
satirique comme les comme les gens
parlent toujours de la des racines de
etc je me suis dit on va faire une
expérience chimiquement pur un type qui
n'a jamais connu l'endroit où il est né
parce que je suis né en algérie mais que
j ai passé huit jours
quand ils y retournent quel effet ça
fait ce cas une vibration il ya quelque
chose
y'avait rien moi je suis retourné à
coulommiers comme sa marque 14e souvent
vous est venue assez rapidement
effectivement votre famille s'est
installée en france enfin en métropole à
neuilly et vous dites j'ai été victime
de l'antisémitisme à l'école quand la
première fois quand on m'a dit que
j'avais pas droit à des jouets pour noël
parce que mes ancêtres avaient tué jésus
il savait pas que jésus était juif le
plus qui vous ont dit ça et pourtant
c'était déjà après vatican 2 mais oui le
gamin qui m'a dit ça c'est quand même
était pas mais j'aimerais ça a été sans
doute un de mes un de mes très très
grand chagrin d'enfance oui je suis
rentré je suis rentré chez moi très en
larmes chez les pros fâché a déploré
tout seul parce que j'étais fier mais
j'ai beaucoup beaucoup pleuré à l'idée
que je n'ai pas droit de fêter noël
ouais bien sûr savoir ce que damas qui
en jette comme j'étais dans j'ai été
élevé dans une famille juive totalement
assimilés ont fêté noël comme tout le
monde bien sûr avec l'arbre de noël avec
les cadeaux avec caen jusqu'à 4 ans et
demi
quelqu'un j'ai le père noël est là
l'idée que je n'y avaient pas droit
était une espèce de l'apocalypse white
catastrophe d'enfants votre père a fait
fortune dans le bois dans une entreprise
de bois c'est ça et après sa mort la
boîte était vendu à françois pinault
c'est lui qui a financé françois pinault
vos films
c'est mon père et françois pinault clan
produits film votre père quand vous êtes
devenu célèbre il était ça l'énervé
beaucoup facile attendre les taxis oui
c'est vrai absolument pourquoi parce
qu'il avait gagné son argent la surdité
parce qu'il était plus conséquent que
moi plus raisonnable qu'il avait un sens
de l'argent plus
oui sûrement plus responsable que moi et
que l'idée en effet c'est je sais pas où
vous avez lu ça mais c'est exact l'idée
d'un taxi dont le taximètre tourné
pendant que je venais
le voir lagacé au plus haut point il
avait l'impression que c'était oui de
l'argent je n'étais pas laisser les
comprends je crois qu'il a oui ils
avaient tort alors en 66 vous êtes
excusés mais j'étais un mauvais garçon
après de ce point de vue là ouais et
plus de quelques autres en 66 et exclut
de sciences po voilà pas le pourquoi je
tiens un peu blousons dorés c'est ça non
parce que j'avais j'avais frappé mon
maître de conférences je vous avais fait
il je l'avais trouvé très désagréable au
conseiller fâché
voilà j'ai eu cette bagarre à j'ai été
très bon j'étais à ses bagages
non mais quand le gloupier de vous
emporter je me souviens qu'une fois
voulu vraiment frappé quoi je déteste la
bagarre je trouve que c'est quelque
chose d'épouvantable que le spectacle de
deux mecs qui se battent est une chose
horrible mais mais voilà ici ça m'arrive
de le faire j'ai fait j'ai appris à me
battre quand j'étais très jeune et si il
arrive que ça revienne
je peux le faire signer mais j'essaie de
soigner le marché fait très longtemps
que j'avais pas d'arriver chez en quelle
année xavier normale sup alors normal
subis étaient entre 68 et 72
un jour vous êtes vous sécher un cours
et vous avez dans une cave enfumée rue
d'ulm donc c'est l'époque de mai 68 et
c'est la première session du premier
congrès de l'ujc donc jcml voilà
marxiste léniniste toute la différence
et dans le fer entre parenthèses mjc
parenthèses ll oui et alors là cercle on
peut en fumée comme ça avec les vrais
révolutionnaires et
il vous arrivait et pour vous vous dites
que vraiment pour vous ça c'est incarne
toute l'aristocratie du moment les gens
qui sont là c'est ce qui se fait de
mieux et vous dites oui on vous parle de
quelqu'un et au lieu de 10 roland
barthes vous dit roland barthez parce
que roland barthes voulait toujours vu
écrit et vous savez pas comment ça se
prononce dans ce coup il ya une clameur
indignés dans la dans la réunion le
copain est avec vous qui olivier cohen
est absolument catastrophique vous ayez
pu faire une gaffe comme ça il vous
regarde et vous dit on est foutu ad oui
une classe d'hypokhâgne s'éteint c'est
un salon de trousses on est chez les
guermantes ou chez les verdurin dire
barre à arriver de nuit dans un milieu
d'étudiants
révolutionnaire frotter aux moeurs fait
du quartier latin et dire barthez c'est
un coup de pistolet dans un concert
c'est épouvantable oui mais vous
débrouiller tellement bien dans la vie
je suis ravi d'avoir retrouvé de 3
gaffes comme à l'époque où vous en
faisait encore un jour on vous présente
derrida et et vous dites
première fois envoyé jacques derrida
grands philosophes et vous dites je
connais votre cou ce trinquet
pharmaciens qui me fournit cern
amphétamines et il ne l'a jamais
pardonné ça faisait des années que je me
fournis cernant fait chez son cousin est
le cousin de cesser à chaque fois que je
venais me parlait alors des rides à
jacky etc et le pharmacien le prenais
pour un pour un raté c'était un prospère
amistad un grand et gros pharmaciens et
pour lui derrida c'était le petit
dernier de la famille qui avait raté son
truc
donc moi fraternelle jeudi à derrida en
61 ans vous passez la grecque de philo
vous êtes maoïstes à cette époque là non
je suis maso is an oui ça veut dire quoi
je ne suis pas ça veut dire que je ne
suis pas militant maoïste
c'est à dire que vous adorez le
président mao par exemple non ça veut
dire que je pense à l'époque en effet
qui se passe quelque chose de très
important en chine mais moi mon maoïsme
je suis allé chercher très loin
puisqu'en 71e vous partez au bangladesh
à l'appel de malraux comme reporter de
guerre pour combat j'entends à la
télévision malraux convulsé ticket
magnifique pathétique et magnifique
appelé à la constitution d'une brigade
internationale
je sais qu'il ya dans les maquis du
bangladesh des groupes maoïstes qui
payent comptant leur vie et le danger et
le trafic est en effet je décide d'y
aller j'y passe j'ai pas su que j'y
passe quelques mois six mois mais gens
rapportent à livre qui est paru chez
maspéro l'année d'après vous souvenez
des maristes filipova oui travail non
j'admire le parcours de
bernard henri lévy parce que moi j'étais
un journaliste engagé mais par deux
directeurs de médias ce oui j'ai jamais
trouvé une grande cause une occasion
d'aller avec les stries si vous mettez
avec vous mes amis yvelines cause jamais
une cause sérieusement j'ai jamais un
chien y avait des cours je ne vais pas
annoncer tout est alors en rentrant de
saab ont republié effectivement votre
premier bouquin qui est ressorti sous le
titre les indes rouge et vous rendez
visite à mitterrand et là c'est un peu
comme le sketch de bigard c'est à dire
que d'abord il est vive à voir
mitterrand lui disant je veux bosser
avec vous je vais être un expert auprès
de vous alors il dit est ce que je peux
prendre l'université à lens a fait
universités ces prêts est ce que je peux
prendre les rapports avec les
intellectuels à annonce à ses prix et
donc il vous est resté l'autogestion non
il dit en revanche j'ai non il dit j'ai
une idée pour vous j'ai un type qui me
qui m'empoisonne un peu la vie qui
s'appelle jean pierre chevènement un
jeune socialiste et qui a une marotte me
dit mitterrand c'est l'autogestion je
sais pas ce que ça veut dire c'est à ce
moment je n'y crois pas mais ça
m'emmerde
est ce que vous voudrez pas vous occuper
de l'autogestion mais vous voilà devenu
spécialiste des spéciales du jour au
lendemain je deviens spécialistes de
l'auteur estimant qu'au parti socialiste
groupe d experts c'est sympa non ge a du
culot bernard henri lévy alors après bon
on va pas faire tout votre vie comme ça
mois après mois mais vous lancer en les
nouveaux philosophes quand même qu'ils
étaient quand même quelque chose qui a
marqué en 77 à barbarie à visage humain
vous naissez apostrophe alors allez pas
vous opposiez enfin c'était une idée des
nouveaux philosophes c'est à dire
c'était l'idée d'opposer le finalement
ne considérer que le stalinisme le
nazisme c'était un peu la même chose
c'est en tous les cas deux
totalitarismes et comme disait
d'ormesson ici d'ailleurs le le drame du
20e siècle a été d'être obligé de
choisir entre deux totalitarismes dans
la barbarie à visage humain en 80
l'idéologie française alors là vous
dites vous rappeler aux gens que le
fascisme est une invention qui n'est pas
calme en deux clics un peu française
aussi 1 alors à part ça faisait publier
des romans
vous avez aimé 10 684 pour le diable en
tête l'intérêt 10 ans 89 pour le dernier
jour de charles baudelaire en 93
d'épouser arielle dombasle
oui ça marche toujours
[Musique]
vous avez résisté aux l'amour dure trois
ans comme dit frédéric beigbeder ou sept
ans dont on parle toujours et moi j'ai
une théorie moi je crois que là je crois
pas l'usure je crois pas à la à
l'inévitable usure des sentiments je
crois que c'est pas vrai je crois que
les c'est pour d'autres raisons que ça
que les gens ne s'aiment plus et quand
vous la fait tourner et arielle dombasle
dans le jour et la nuit et qu'elle tombe
dans les bras d'alain delon faisait pas
jaloux sérieusement sérieusement bah oui
alors si raison je peux je ne suis pas
jaloux pour une raison ouais mais je
sais pas si je peux vous le dire
pourquoi on est entre nous la salle il y
avait des caméras mais c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai jamais c'est quelque
chose que je n'ai jamais dit très
important donc on va bien écoutez il ya
une scène en effet il ya une scène
d'amour dans le film dans le jour et la
nuit entre arielle dombasle et alain
delon qui est une scène que je trouve
très belle d'ailleurs où on voit leurs
deux corps en ombres chinoises de très
loin à travers des rideaux de corps en
ombres chinoises
et comme en effet je suis assez jaloux
vous avez raison ça n'est pas anodin
c'est vous bravo et la gagner
c'est moi c'est moi vous avez pensé que
vous seriez meilleur parce que parce que
delon comme moi aimions mais sachez le
côté for me d'abord en ombres chinoises
je suis un acteur potable à l'est de
londres ne voulait pas être ombres
chinoises et que non on s'était mis
d'accord alain delon et moi et alain
delon d'ailleurs d'une manière tout à
fait ça c'est sympathique animal puis je
vais la cantoche non ne faites pas vos
gros titres là alors pour en revenir à
ce film
les cahiers du cinéma ont dû marquer
c'est pas mal quelques pas le plus
mauvais le film de toute l'histoire du
cinéma
c'est incroyable je ne serai ce qui
arrive à faire ça quand même
j'étais très fier de la critique des
cahiers du cinéma d'un monsieur tubiana
oui c'est ça oui je trouvais ça
formidable
le plus mauvais film de toute l'histoire
c'est que quand on fait on n'est pas sûr
de ça mais quand on sait à la fin qu'on
y est arrivé beaucoup mais il est gelé
vu le film
ah bon c'était vous
non la question et s'est fait allumer
vous l'avez dit vous êtes l'allumé pour
vos essais plus rarement pour vos romans
est-ce que là le film c'était grave mais
ce que vous allez continuer à faire des
films
ah oui ah bon est-ce que je vais
continuer oui bien entendu oui avec j'en
ai même très très envie et puis ça ça
menace même vous cacher je ne vous ai
balancé secrets de fabrique c'est fini
pour toi autre chose maintenant ça sera
l'un de l'autre objet de s'y coller
maintenant on va faire une interview
joue
comme je vois dernier se marrent
évidemment je n'ai pas bien alors
l'interview vous ou c'est pas compliqué
je vous jeter des noms comme ça comme
des pigeons d'argile et donc des
pompiers vous allez faire comme ça ou
pas voilà alors qu'est-ce que j'ai passé
à moi non mais moi je le ferai quand
vous allez balance et je vais faire ça
quand vous allez dire du mal je vais
faire
[Applaudissements]
je dois dire du mal de chacun des nord
vous dites ce que vous voulez le accord
va bien entendu on est libre ici va y
avoir des gens sympas recommencer on a
commencé très très sympa edouard
balladur
je pense qu'il aurait fait un bon maire
de paris peut-être pas un bon président
de la république mais un bon maire de
paray philippe seguin qui risque d'être
maire de paris sa mauvaise humeur
perpétuelle me fascine
françoise de panafieu j'aime pas les
rollers tiberi mai mais j'aime bien la
famille panafieu gaulliste et c'est
l'offre tiberi jean tiberi bouc
émissaire est sûrement brave type
sûrement brave type points et courageux
de dire ça voilà un mec est victime d'un
lynchage médiatique
[Applaudissements]
je vais même de nous arrêter même quand
même quand même n'exagérons rien
jacques chirac bon maire de paris
miraculé miraculé c'est clair jospin
héros moyens pour classe pompe pour
classes moyennes
vous pensez que la france est devenue
une puissance moyenne donc il faut caler
des présidents moyens oui et ça sera un
bon président moyen âge moyen d'accords
laurent fabius personnages on ressort à
8,2 roman pourquoi parce que je trouve
passionnant parce que je n'ai pas un
personnage de roman politique c'est un
type qui démarre très jeune qui monte
très haut et qui tombe très bas rhin et
puis qui s'en relève vrai bon bah voilà
cette espèce de résurrection fabiusienne
je trouve ça pour un romancier je suis
amateur de sa de type humain c'est
intéressant dominique strauss kahn le
meilleur de tous est donc la meilleure
cible
ouais c'est pour ça qu'on a flingué les
manuels et jour socialisme cassoulet
cassoulet mais arbre quand même un
socialiste durer leurs méchants comme sa
bouille sympathique chez vous il chez
vous il était sympathique birmane était
bon mais ce qui faisait exprès qu'il
faisait semblant non c'est plus un poème
et peut-être krivine papy fait de la
fait la révolution s'arrête parce que là
vous étiez bon quand la main j'aurais
adoré charles cros a oui mais moi oui ça
c'est un de mes grands vins proposés
dont je suis je suis un peu qu'il en
soit je suis un peu des shoots et des
médias mais c'est vrai qu'une chose que
j'aurais aimé faire je peux vous le dire
maintenant c'est lé brossette
c'est pourquoi je sais pas je veux juger
trop trop sérieux
or trop engagés pour venir avec ba voila
c'est vrai qu'on fait ça merci les
grands malentendus de la vie c'est ça
honte à vous remercie parce que vous
avez été une inspiration pour beaucoup
de comics c'est vrai est encore passé
mitterrand françois et
artiste artiste au sens où vous disais
tout à l'heure
pas seulement parce qu'il écrivait bien
artistes de lui-même martelly de
mensonges artistes de la politique
artiste de gaulle plus grands artistes
artistes number ones l'espèce de
campagne comme ça en ti de gaulle qui en
ce moment le livre de zinc en ski tout
ça ça vous ça vous fait quoi cette
espèce de volonté de le pérenniser
finalement je trouve ça
je trouve ça assez dégueulasse parce que
pour moi il ya quand même le projet
appartient vous me parliez tout à
l'heure de mon père il ya une chose que
en tout cas il m'a appris de mon père
était un anti fasciste de la première
heure
est-ce pas de 1937 engagé volontaire en
1939 au début de la guerre et puis
français libres et il m'a toujours
appris une chose c'est que ceux de
gaulle le de gaulle de l'appel du 18
juin 40 était un personnage auquel nous
devions vous et moi
et puis déjà défini ci présente
d'exister sans ça on serait pas là elle
dit
le pen
bon débarras ouais je trouvais pas ça un
peu suspect comme ça que du jour au
lendemain on n'en parle plus est ce que
finalement il quand on dit qu'il avait
été montée en épingle par mitterrand
pour briser la droite c'est vrai
qu'aujourd'hui quand même on n'en parle
plus du tout est ce que c'est à cause de
lui ou à cause des médias
mitterrand avait beaucoup de défauts on
enfin il était quand même pas derrière
chacun des 15 % d'électeurs qui mettait
le moulin à votre le pen dans les urnes
pasqua cas surtout l'essentiel on arrête
avec le pen c'est fini il va être
bientôt démis de son mandat européen et
ça sera très bien comme ça pasqua
fernandel ouais
fernandel mais c'est gentil oui je sais
ça pourrait être pire je pouvais dire un
le pen républicaine on va dire ferment
des ati villiers philippe de vider un
bon imitateur de laurent gerra way
madelin un cohn-bendit de droite
ouais bien joué ppda ppda petit prince
de l'audimat c'est gentil lara pivot
bernard pivot j'espère que vous ne
remplacerez pas inoxydable
j'espère qu'il restera longtemps à son
émission mais moi aussi
voilà j'ai bien géré ses bons jours chez
lui vous l'avez l'iressa se retrouve en
marche bien et j'espère que pivot
tiendra julien sorel julien sorel
vieux frère perdu du rubin près petit
frère perdu de vue martignac rastignac
à nous de paris tout ça thierry ardisson
of clinton tussauds j'allais oublier
arielle dombasle la femme de ma vie
alors de cuivre auscitain est un gros
succès
tout le monde en parle ça se vend très
très bien et pourtant le titre est pas
facile hein vous avez fait des trucs
plus simple il y avait et loge des
intellectuels l'idéologie française
le testament de dieu le siècle de sartre
bon là le titre un peu compliqué malgré
tout les gens l'achètent le titre ses
réflexions sur la guerre le mal et la
fin de l'histoire
précédé de lait damné de la guerre voilà
qu'est ce qu'ils font les gens dans les
librairies demande le nouveau bernard
henri lévy j'imagine ce que le titre est
un peu impossible mais c'est pas c'était
le titre que ça t'es sérieux c'est
chercher à faire du marketing
vous savez comment on fait
bien alors le contenu est double au
départ il y avait une série de
reportages pour le journal le monde dans
des pays où existe ce que vous appelez
des guerres oubliées
l'angola le burundi la colombie le sri
lanka le soudan
et ça ça fait à peu près 120 pages de
votre nouveau livre et puis un petit peu
comme sur les ordinateurs vous cliquez
sur des mots firca le texte et
l'hypertexte vous cliquez sur des mots
et vous développez dans une deuxième
partie
certains points de la première partie à
travers des fragments et le style est
très différend entre les deux parties a
un style reportage très bien écrit très
très punchy comme ça et puis un style
plus analytique dans les fragments alors
le livre est un succès mais je me
demande si c'est pas finalement pour de
mauvaises raisons
bien sûr c'est agréable d'avoir du
succès surtout que ce livre marque pour
vous d'une certaine façon la fin d'une
excommunication qui avait commencé avec
l'idéologie française
un livre qui traitait du fascisme à la
française et puis avait aussi votre film
le jour et la nuit
la fin de cette excommunication s'est
amorcé avec le siècle de sartre qui nous
a réconciliés avec la gauche est
aujourd'hui ce livre est un succès je
dis peut-être pas pour les bonnes
raisons
dans tous les cas ça y est quoi vous
êtes revenu dans le grand bain oui
le succès c'est toujours des mauvaises
raisons cela je crois je le crois
vraiment je crois qu'un écrivain il a
s'est nourrie cie'kid hissage la raison
un écrivain à quelques milliers de
lecteurs quand on arrive quand un
écrivain avant des dizaines de milliers
ou des centaines de milliers de livres
c'est presque toujours un malentendu
alors là il ya sûrement entendu aussi
dans lequel les secours on avait repéré
oui je les repérer c'est à dire que
c'est normal c'est d'actualité comme
vous avez été en
il ya une trentaine d'années déjà au
bangladesh à l'époque comme vous avez
bien connu le commandant massoud
tout le monde va parler de massoud
évidemment comment il était qu'est ce
qu'ils faisaient qu'est ce qu'il ferait
s'il était là et c'est bon votre
ambition en fait c'était passé là au
départ même si l'actualité a donné un
relief particulier à votre livre au
départ votre ambition c'était de parler
de ces guerres oubliées ces guerres qui
n'ont pas de sens et guerre insensée
comme vous dites alors que la guerre en
afghanistan a un sens c'était c'est une
guerre en réaction au 11 septembre c'est
une guerre contre le fascisme vert donc
c'est différent c'est vrai que le projet
du livre ce n'était pas ça c'était
d'aller enquêter d'aller regarder du
côté de ceux dont on ne parle jamais
malade parce que l'afghanistan sais
c'est un peu quand même l'arbre qui
cache la forêt tous les projecteurs du
monde sont aujourd'hui fixés sur
l'afghanistan
alléluia il ya d'autres guerres encore
plus sanglante
alors plus terrible que la guerre
d'algérie on va en parler mais avant d'y
dépasser au contenu du livre ameline
après ce que vous avez déclaré titre
alors maintenant j'attends qu'ils
approchaient d'un garçon tout le monde
se dit que les problèmes
elle veut devenir esclave sexuelle
qu'est ce que je vous dis donc avant de
passer au contenu du livre on va évacuer
aussi des critiques qui vous ont été
faites notamment pas arnaud viviant du
style bhl fait du tourisme guerrier
comme houellebecq fait du tourisme
sexuel et c'est vrai que vous avez une
vie bon c'est clair
votre vie est une alternance comme ça
entre des moments très pénibles ce que
vous vivez dans les endroits dont vous
parlez dans votre bouquin et puis aussi
c'est vrai la colombe d'or les
qu'arielle dombasle boulevard
saint-germain à paris est ce que c'est
interdit d'être les deux à neuf pas du
tout non mais évacuons le nom mais
apparemment il ya certain que ça gêne
c'est vrai que pour l'instant ce qui est
important je crois c'est pas la colombe
d'or c'est qu'en effet j'ai passé
l'année dernière à aller dans ces trous
noirs de la planète c'est-à-dire là où
le malheur est maximale et dans des
endroits dont tout le monde se moque
soyons clairs et soyons francs des
images du burundi à la télévision il y
en a pas des masses
des images l'angola y en a pas des
reportages sur les noubas y en a pas
donc j'ai essayé de faire 5 voilà pour
quelles raisons ça c'est une autre en
même temps on se servir de son statut de
star pour témoigner pourquoi pas je veux
dire c'est ce que fait goldman quand il
fait les restos du coeur en même temps
elle utilise
mais j'aurais été procédé l'époux je
crois que c'est ce qu'on peut faire de
mieux d'une notoriété vous rendait ce
que la vie vous a donné je rends oui
mais je crois que c'est ce que doivent
faire
comment vous dire je crois que c'est un
devoir quand on a reçu beaucoup c'est la
moindre des choses de rendre un peu et
un intellectuel ça peut servir à ça sk
pas quelque chose d'une explication un
peu chrétienne dans cette idée de se
faire pardonner finalement ça bernard
aurait dit chrétien c'est un c'est un
vrai scoop là alors on passe au contenu
du livre maintenant donc ces cinq
reportages dans cinq pays ravagé par des
guerres dont personne ne parle
vous avez des trous noirs de l'actualité
en tous les cas ça fait pas le 20h ça
c'est clair
nouveau type de guerre parce que c'est
vrai que depuis la chute du communisme
c'est plus des guerres de libération
nationale ou des guerres de résistance à
l'oppression
c'est des guerres sans le sens qui
desanneaux glisser d'une certaine façon
le communisme donner un sens à tous
c'est à dire que c'était une espèce de
grande machine planétaire qui faisait
que n'importe quel guérilla aux îles
moluques ou au fond du fond du sud
soudan était rattaché un combat mondial
les uns étaient du côté des américains
les autres étaient du côté des des
russes etc
et c'est vrai que le communisme en
s'effondrant c'est comme une espèce de
marée qui se seraient retirés et qu'ils
laissent sur la grève des gens qui
continuent de se battre avec une
férocité inouïe moi j'ai vu des choses
et j'ai rapporté des choses dans ce
livre qui que je n'arrive pas à oublier
enfin qu'ils sont qui sont au-delà en
tout cas de l'imagination et ça n'a plus
de sens vous dira interrogé aujourd'hui
un angolais un an gaulle et 10 à 20 ans
il avait l'impression moi je rends
compte par exemple à porto un boy qui
est une petite ville du sud de l'angola
je rencontre un vieux portugais qui
était un des premiers progressiste e
rallye au mp relais qui me dit il ya 20
ans j'avais l'impression de me battre
pour le communisme l'international
maguer avait un sens aujourd'hui je ne
sais plus pourquoi je me va je suis
comme un canard sans tête qui
continueraient de courir n'apporte des
tisons lâcher la corde qu'il est relié à
l'universel voilà et c'est vrai que
jusqu'ici les galettes et la
continuation de la politique par
d'autres moyens
aujourd'hui c'est la continuation de
rien du tout ils se battent soit la
continuation du tout soit dans certains
cas la continuation de la religion par
d'autres moyens
ça n'est plus la continuation ces
guerres dont je parle ça n'est plus là
quand il dit à l'horreur de mourir
s'ajoute celle de mourir pour rien non
seulement y meurt mais ils savent pas
pourquoi ils n'ont aucune espèce d'idée
des raisons pour lesquelles il pourrait
mourir plus grave que ça comment arrêter
une guerre qui n'a pas de sens c'est à
dire n'y a pas de raison de l'arrêté
s'allumant ils savent pas pourquoi ils
se battent c'est une espèce d'animalité
postes historiques qui rejoint un peu
les combats préhistorique d'une certaine
façon sur des tribus qui se battent sans
vraiment savoir pourquoi on rejoint
d'après l'histoire non alors en même
temps c'est plus compliqué que ça passe
que par exemple dans le cas du soudan je
suis allé au sud soudan où j'avais le
sentiment en un premier temps qu'en
effet c'était une guerre absurde une
guerre tribale
et puis regardons de plus près et même
d'ailleurs sur le moment puisque le
hasard a fait que j'ai survolé un champ
pétrolifère en activant fin en
préparation autour duquel l'armée
soudanaise avait nettoyé les villages au
sud soudan c'est ça vous avez les
compagnies pétrolières qui s'installe et
20 km 30 km 100 km autour on brûle les
maisons on chasse les gens on liquide ce
qui n'obtempère pas et vous voyez des
petites colonnes de pauvres gens avec un
maigre balle l'eau sur la tête tout ce
qu'ils ont pu emporter de leur vie
d'avant qui skie qui partent plus loin
alors là par exemple il ya un sens là
c'est clairement le régime islamiste de
khartoum
appuyez sur les grandes compagnies
pétrolières canadiennes malaise
peut-être demain française il ya
aujourd'hui un projet pétrolier dans une
région du sud soudan total fina elf
vieille connaissance tout de même
et là c'est cette alliance diabolique un
cette alliance terrible entre le pouvoir
islamiste et les pétroliers qui fait que
les gens sont jetés sur les routes est
traité comme du bétail
donc là on revient dans une logique qui
n'est pas une logique insensée
donc c'est très compliqué vous savez
c'est un livre il n'ya pas de ya pas de
régaler pas dire pas de réponse il
regarde certitude sur la queue du doigt
là c'est bien sûr via book bon enfin y'a
pas que dire de se dire beaucoup
oui c'est vrai en un sens oui ça oui
bien sûr parce que ça me change un peu
c'est vrai qu'il m'est arrivé c'est vrai
d'être plus sûre de moi mais vous en
rejoint
ce que vous dites des fois un peu perdu
je suis rentré je suis rentré ce livre
là c'est un effet laventure la plus la
plus terrible de mets vins c'est la
première aventure politique dont je ne
sois pas redevenu intacte inde m
et c'est vrai que j'en reviens avec
autant de l'otan a serti du coffret
l'évidence que vous racontez pas de
ville fantôme peuplé de spectre des
épaves des ville jonchées de cadavres
mais comme vous dites ainsi nommé et un
compte et c'est à dire que là on
n'enterre pas les gens dont se
repaissent des chiens trop gros là vous
voyez l'enfer quoi c'est dire que vous
découvrez cette lèpre qui est en train
de ronger le monde un petit peu une
lèpre lente langue un peu comme ceux qui
ont sont revenus des camps de
concentration c'est à dire qu'ils ont vu
l'horrible convenu l'indicible et je
pense qu'il fallait pas voir les choses
sont pas ce ne sont jamais comparable et
notamment dans ce cas là mais c'est vrai
que le spectacle par exemple un exemple
précis parce qu'en effet les villes
fantômes tout ça ça peut paraître très
abstrait ou à ceux qui nous écoutent
mais par exemple un jour dans un village
des monts nuba je suis tombé sur une
petite case mate de rondins et de paille
où il y avait trois hommes et un petit
enfant en train de mourir de faim en
train d'achever de mourir de faim il
n'était pas blessé il n'avait pas reçu
une balle il était juste exemple il
était il y avait un des hommes qui
portaient un petit garçon contre lui qui
lui murmurait de temps en temps une
phrase que l'enfant n'entendait pas il y
en avait un autre dont on avait
l'impression qu'il était mort déjà par
endroits et qui avait que je ne sais pas
assez je me souviens de ces mains qui
continuait de de remuer kessé une gratte
et la chemise de se tendre on avait
l'impression que les les mains étaient
comme des organes étrangers qui vivaient
encore alors que le reste est des morts
le troisième l'oeil et et vitreux il
était apparemment vivant est déjà mort
ce spectacle là un l'image de trois
hommes et d'un enfant en train de
s'éteindre de faim dans l'impuissance
absolue de celui qui était là c'est à
dire moi j'étais à des heures de à des
jours de marché à des heures de tout
autre moyen de locomotion de toute base
connue
j'avais un vague talkie walkie que tu
démontres adducteurs ont essayé par tous
les moyens
évidemment personne
et cette image là d'abord elle et elle
est inoubliable et ces situations là
c'est les situations de ces guerres
oubliées contemporain alors ça donne le
vertige votre bouquin parce qu'à un
moment on se dit et si la fin du monde
si la fin des temps c'était cette
abomination on n'a jamais pensé à ça
nous on a une vision progressiste des
choses on pense que peu ou prou c'est
quand même de mieux en mieux et on se
dit en lisant le bouquin sur tout et si
ça se termine comme ça j'en surtout nous
en effet que nous appartenons à une
génération qui a cru moi quand j'avais
20 ans je pensais qu'il y aurait une fin
de l'histoire mais je pensais qu'elle
serait que ce serait une apocalypse
joyeuse envoyé en gros que ce serait la
révolution et c'est vrai que la danse
est dans ces situations-là en colombie
par exemple qui est un pays en proie à
des à la guerre des mafias où vous avez
aidé où on fait la chasse aux clochards
dans les égouts de la ville où on fait
la chasse aux mômes
il ya des contrats qui sont mis sur la
tête des mômes d'un quartier on prend 20
gosses parce qu'ils mangent des rares
parce qu'ils font baisser l'immobilier
du quartier en gros sa gelée je le
raconte dans le livre
un groupe d'enfants dont le principal
tort est de faire baisser les prix de
l'immobilier du quartier il ya un ancien
flic qui rassemble les voisins qui crée
une junte de nettoyage social ou la
route adélie mme pieza sociale qui met
un contrat sur la tête des vins môme et
puis on les courses et on l'est on les
flingues l'un après l'autre
donc c'est vrai que là on a l'impression
d'un ordre social qui se délite d'une
société qui s'est dès qu'ils se
détruisent l'intérieur d'une histoire
qui s'achève sauf que au lieu d'être cet
acharnement joyeux que nous imaginions
et qu'imaginaient les philosophes c'est
une
c'est un achèvement sinistre c'est un
achèvement désastreux désastreux c'est
plus l'astre de la révolution à un
dialysé le le désastre de l'inhumanité
vous dormez comment la nuit depuis que
vous êtes revenu
ça dépend des jours ça dépend des jours
comme je suis en effet comme vous le
disiez tout à l'heure je suis un un
tempérament heureux et je suis assez
fort pour être double bien sûr donc je
m'arrive de dormir pas trop mal mais il
m'arrive alors s'ils ont foulé le fond'
il m'arrive en effet d'être d'avoir tout
ça qui me revient c'est vrai et d'avoir
le sentiment en plus cons
croit souvent les correspondants de
guerre où les gens qui assistent à des
choses de ce genre
il m'arrive d'avoir pas le regret est
presque là presque la honte de n'avoir
fait que passer quand ce type là dont
vous parliez parle de tourisme guerrier
bien sûr qu'il a raison évidemment qu'on
fait toujours du tourisme guerrier quand
on va passer quinze jours trois semaines
un mois - autrefois j'ai passé six mois
au bangladesh en effet ce annexe i - on
s'en va les autres restent et le grand
partage de l'humanité vous savez c'est
ça c'est ceux qui restent et ceux qui ne
font que passer ça c'est incontestable
alors c'est vrai que la nuit à ce que le
billet de retour ce sont bien de retour
voilà alors ça c'est l'inégalité c'est
plus un c'est plus important que
l'inégalité entre les riches et les
pauvres c'est plus important qu'une
égalité entre les entre les jolies et
les moins joli c'est plus important que
tout ça l'inégalité de en gros d'être né
dans un lieu de damnation et date
revenez dans un lieu de nantis voilà est
ce dire c'est en effet le petit effort
modeste d'un antique qui a essayé
d'aller y voir de l'autre côté du miroir
comment ça se passe de l'autre côté de
l'apartheid planétaire parce que c'est
ça qui se passe mais aujourd'hui les
pays occidentaux ils ont fait un appart
heinze est pas l'apartheid d'afrique du
sud 1
c'est un apartheid mondial avec d'un
côté les les pays riches pas seulement
l'europe est passablement l'occident il
ya des pays arabes qui sont très riches
par exemple et puis de l'autre côté
c'est ces trous noirs ces trous nombril
du monde
c'est no man's land ces zones grises un
trou noir en astronomie vous savez c'est
un c'est une densité très grande trêve
de plus en plus grande à mesure que le
lieu se résorbe et là c'est un peu ça le
burundi c'est un lieu qui se résorbent
sur la carte nos imaginaires il existe
de moins en moins ils occupent de moins
en moins de place et puis tout se passe
comme si la la densité de malheurs et de
souffrance s'accroissait en conséquence
les réflexions sur la terre
hélas l'histoire de céder 2 cette année
chez grasset merci
[Musique]
merci en tous les cas de ce témoignage
c'est ce qu'on va faire maintenant un
anti portrait chinois ont la bouche
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
beaucoup de portrait chinois ça veut
dire il ya le portrait chinois si vous
étiez une fleur je serai à myosotis et
l'anti portrait chinois par exemple
c'est si vous étiez un défaut si j'étais
un défaut ouais si j'annonce si j'étais
un défaut grec est le défaut vous seriez
l'esprit de sérieux je crois que je
crains c'est bien si vous étiez une
injure
le silence si vous étiez une maladie la
lucidité un accident la chance une
perversion le goût du secret si vous
étiez un vice si j'étais un vice la
cybèle fera le si beau titre de larbaud
ce vice impuni la lecture si j'étais
invite je serai la lecture une trahison
je serai comme ces gens qui militent
tous qui se bat contre leur tribu contre
leur camp par exemple je ne sais pas les
aristocrates ou les prêtres français en
89 qui rejoignait le tiers état c'est
une des plus belles attitudes me
semble-t-il ceux qui choisissent de
penser contre eux mêmes ou contrôler
leur penser contre soi même pensée
contraire mais oui ou contre les siens
les pieds noirs qui devenait porto qui
prenait le parti du fln pendant la
guerre d'algérie
ça ça me semble une attitude très noble
city est une arme
si j'étais une arme un stylo c'est le
seul dont je suis capable de me servir
c'est la différence entre vous et naba
bull a répondu un cutter la semaine
dernière moi ce sera sûrement d'autres
et différence cette interview que ça
permet de si vous étiez un supplice la
volupté une cicatrice le souvenir
notamment des volutes et si vous étiez
un poison la vérité dont ce génie s'il
disait qu'elle était le poison des
dictatures que lesdits nature se
corroder par le travail de la vérité se
situe une panne jours je crois que
j'essaierai de dérégler d'envoyer un
virus dans les derniers ordinateurs de
ben laden
avec lequel il est sans doute en train
de préparer ses prochains attentats un
dictateur si j'étais un dictateur
j'oblige ray et thierry ardisson a
diffusé chaque samedi 10 minutes en
boucle l'image de l'angola et du burundi
que de voir si vous êtes une infirmité
si j'étais une infirmité la surdité plus
cirer terme et non la patience
l'impatience moi c'est probablement mon
mon pire défaut enfin voilà la patience
and assassins
si j'étais un assassin jeu j'essaierai
d'assassiner pam avoisinera surgit la
mauvaise part de moi-même que je connais
bien et ça en général c'est un crime
parfait ni même celui là si vous étiez à
microbes
j'essaierai d'être un d'être un microbe
sympathique des train d'être un microbe
de gauche qui irait chercher de
préférence les [ __ ] mais parfois les
combes et surtout dans les salles aux
microbes sélectif une torture
je ne sais pas si je voulais torturer
quelqu'un je crois que ce serait la
différence
voilà une humiliation je me suiciderai
parce que je si j'étais une imitation
jeu mais je crois que je ne supporterai
ni d'être humilié ni encore moins de
supporter l'humiliation des autres donc
je disparaîtrai dans votre nuage de
fumée jugement dernier serge lama
j'accompagnerai salamanque l'oratoire
c'est un jeu temps devant vous si vous
étiez un terroriste je serai le colonel
fabien
c'est à dire je serai un bon terrorisme
la définition d'un bon terroristes c'est
quelqu'un qui défend une juste cause et
qui n'a pas d'autre moyen que la
violence de la défendre donc posé des
bombes dans paris en 42 ce colonel
fabien
ça je crois que c'est du bon terrorisme
et ça n'a évidemment rien à voir avec
cette caricature que sont les
terroristes d'aujourd'hui c'est comme
faire la guerre sans l'aimer quoi c'est
comme faire la guerre sans l'aimer qui
était un mot de malraux et qui est elle
a deux filles la devise du commandant
massoud vrai mais si vous étiez une
bourre 3 je serai frechaut serait la
petite mort
j'accueille maintenant bernard
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les limons soir donc à la demande du
président la république et du premier
ministre vous êtes parti pour le quai
d'orsay en mission en afghanistan pour
envisager ce que la france peut faire en
matière de coopération culturelle
d'éducation de développement économique
et social pour la construction d'un état
de droit en afghanistan et de cette
mission vous avez rapporté un rapport
que vous avez remis au début du mois à
jacques chirac et à lionel jospin
un rapport qui est publié chez grasset
et la documentation française voilà
honourable disait récemment dans
l'express que ce rapport qui a été
commandé par l'état
vous l'aviez mis en vente sur le
problème c'est que comme c'est un
rapport officiel la loi républicaine
c'est que je ne touche pas de droit
d'auteur donc c'est un livre sans droits
d'auteur et où les droits d'auteur vont
à la république qui vont à la france qui
vont au quai d'orsay dont est normal
c'est la loi il ya pas de mérite mais
simplement il ya un tout petit peu là de
légèreté dans la formation de votre
honorable confrères oui c'est pas un
honorable confrères pour moi je fais
souvent des conneries l'ont fait
d'autres attendent et l'extrait cela dit
vous savez c'est eux qui ont lancé cette
cette pitoyable affaire di falco espèce
de rumeurs absurdes très certainement
infondée au nom de laquelle on a on a
sali l'honneur d'un homme et d'un prêtre
accusé de pédophilie sur la fin et
dorian témoignage assez is able bombay
aujourd'hui il ya la presse parfois
heureusement pas toujours mais parfois
c'est de ce genre de deux petites
légèreté l'express a expliqué que cette
émission était comparable a love story
de recul allez sur l'a6 pourvoir revenez
vous verrez la différence surtout
surtout que maintenant alors vous dites
au sujet de l'afghanistan la première
chose à faire c'est rétablir la sécurité
dans kaboul sur les routes et notamment
pour les femmes parce que là la grande
question qu'on se pose évidemment quand
on arrive à kaboul et que se pose je
suppose tous les français c est ce que
les femmes ont retiré la burqa cette ce
signe de l'horreur talibans cette prison
de
de maille de coton qu'elle portait sur
la tête et qu'il est qui les humilier
est-ce que la libération avec dix ans
leur a permis de les retirer
réponse non parce qu'elles ont peur
parce qu'elles ont encore peur et elles
ont peur parce qu a pas d'état en
afghanistan parce qu'il n'y a pas d'état
de droit parce qu'il ya pas de casque a
pas de police quoi parce qu'il n'ya pas
d'ordre ni de loi
donc je crois que par exemple pour les
femmes pour qu'elles puissent oser
marcher à nouveau à visage découvert
l'urgence c'est de rétablir un état
absolument et c'est une des
recommandations que j'ai fait à chirac
et jospin est ce que vous êtes sûr que
si les femmes afghanes avaient avaient
le droit de d'enlever leurs burqas en
étant protégé par un état de droit elle
le ferait tout elle le ferait sûrement
pas tout mais je crois qu'elle serait
très nombreux à le faire et quand elles
ne sont pas
dans les grandes villes très souvent
dans le pays à zara par exemple elles
n'ont pas de burqa à bamiyan j'ai eu des
femmes sans burqa et à kaboul avant les
talibans
regardez les images les années 60 des
années 60 ans les rg bois-des-filion je
vous avez vous avez des femmes avec la
burqa et vous avez des femmes en mini
jupe
kylie qui les côtoient vous plairait
d'avoir une burqa oui bien sûr ses juges
en rien à un caractère bien alors pour
l'éducation vous proposait finalement ce
qui s'est passé en france que peggy
appelé les les hussards noirs de la
république c'est-à-dire les instituteurs
de la laïque de la troisième république
un peu comme nous au 18e ou 19e siècle
nous avions une paysannerie qui était
encore souvent au xviiie siècle avoir la
mission française sous l' empire du
féodalisme et qui un siècle plus tard
quand il s'est agit d' envoyer ses
enfants à l'école s'est demandé si le
marché était bon enlevez les fils des
campagnes les retirer des travaux des
champs pour les amener à l'école
obligatoire et les laïcs et puis les 800
noirs de la république de peggy en effet
on dit au père de famille donnez-nous
vos enfants et en retour vous aurez vous
aurez les lumières vous aurez le droit
vous aurez la démocratie alors moi je
pense que c'est un peu la même chose qui
pourrait et qui va se passer en
afghanistan et c'est à ça aussi que
l'état français pourrait aider l'état
vend mais fort de son rayon séculaire
vouloir absolument que les afghans
suivent le sort des français du xviiie
siècle près qu'ils ont envie les avants
précédent destin naturel écoutez je
crois qu'ils ont envie en tout cas il
faut faire attention à deux choses il ya
deux périls symétrique le premier péril
c'est évidemment de vouloir uniformiser
tout ce centrisme européocentrisme et
que la démocratie à l'occidentale
s'impose d'en haut comme les soviétiques
ont imposé le communisme dans o o
campagne afghane on a vu ce que ça a
donné
et puis à l'autre péril qui est aussi
grave qui est de dire il ya des peuples
qui sont bons pour la démocratie il ya
des pommes qui sont pas bon pour la
démocratie il ya des peuples qui sont
pas faits pour les droits de l'homme
il ya des femmes qui sont pas faites
pour marcher à visage découvert et ça
c'est dégueulasse aussi donc je pense
que à condition de respecter les
traditions afghane qui ne nous ont pas
attendus d'ailleurs pour être à leur
manière démocratique qui a une vraie
tradition de démocratie villageoises en
afghanistan à cette condition là on peut
bien sûr un style et le bon esprit
le delà de la démocratie au fin fond de
ce pays alors il ya un truc qui avaient
cru c'est que vous recommander la
création d'une école nationale
d'administration ena procès pack sejima
bein c'est le président karzaï qu'ils
demandent et qui dit abandonner dans wii
dans une des conversations que je
rapporte qu'il écoutait vous avez un
truc formidable en france qui s'appelle
léana je n'ai pas démenti c'était pas
démenti parce que
c'est compliqué l'ena on connaît les
défauts en effet esprit de caste esprit
de clan etc et puis ça a formé aussi une
vraie fonction publique en france l'état
français c'est pas nul
les services publics fonctionnent donc
il à la demande des afghans
c'est ça c'est contre les seigneurs de
la guerre donc contre cette loi delà de
la violence sauvage qui règne dans ce
pays quelque chose qui permettent de
former des gens qui comptent un service
public ses cadres il des cadres de
l'administration
alors les médias aussi évidemment ya
rien là bas pour moment radio télévision
presse
c'est un pays chaos c'est un pays
détruit c'est un pays où tous les tous
les hommes et toutes les femmes de 20
ans 25 ans ne connaissent rien d'autre
que la guerre et la culture de guerre
vous rencontrez sur une route à sur la
route de mazar i sharif des gamins de 25
ans il croit que la relation normale
entre des hommes c'est de se c'est de se
tirer dessus c2c de violer lalalala
femmes qu'il croise
c'est une vraie culture de la violence
et de la guerre donc c'est de tout ça
qu'il faut sortir alors ça va depuis la
création d'une administration jusqu'à la
création d'une radio bien sûr une haie
ou de la télévision qui est cette espèce
de qui peut aider aussi à cette
contagion démocratique lanta laquelle
moi je crois je crois encore une fois je
vous le répète je crois qu'il faut
sortir de l'idée que la démocratie se
serait ce serait bon pour certains et
pas pour d'autres qu'il faudrait des
siècles pour y arriver que ce serait
coûteux la démocratie je crois que celle
inverse qui coûte plus cher c'est là
c'est le despotisme
ce qui coûte plus cher c'est le
totalitarisme ça suppose des flics ça
suppose des des militaires en surnombre
ça suppose des gens qu'ils foutent rien
ça suppose des écoles qui ne fonctionne
pas je crois que la démocratie c'est
presque économiquement plus plus plus
fort pour les plus intéressants pour un
pays alors on parlait tout à l'heure de
sécurité nécessaires à kaboul et sur les
routes d'afghanistan
ça serait nécessaire aussi dans les
banlieues en france c'est la question
qu'on peut se poser
quand on voit votre clip c'est pourquoi
s'occuper de ce qui se passe au bout du
monde et pas de ce qui se passe au coin
de la rue finalement kaboul c'est très
romanesque c'est plus romanesque val
fourré mais croit qu'il faut s'occuper
des deux vous savez quand quand avec
harlem désir ou fodé sylla dans les
années 80 on allait à val fourré on
aller à toulon on allait à vitrolles
il ya quelques années
au moment de l'élection de maigret on
allait les trolls je crois qu'on peut
marcher sur les enfants on peut compter
jusqu'à 2 on peut on peut aller en
afghanistan
quand on a le sentiment pas pour des
raisons romanesque les quand on a le
sentiment d'un peuple à qui l'histoire a
fait une très grande injustice et on
peut aussi s'occuper de val fourré on
peut faire les deux et moi j'essaie de
le faire
mais dernièrement vous êtes a eu le
sentiment que les intellectuels se sont
pas assez occupé du val fourré par
exemple est une des raisons du vote
protestataire de dimanche dernier le vol
pour le vote protestataire ofa le vol
oui c'est un bon la puce parce qu'en
effet c'est un s'étale de pain c'est un
hold up du d'un certain parti politique
sur l'inconscient des français sur ces
peurs sur c'est exaspérant sur leur
exaspération sur leur rancoeur et leur
détresse
enfin c'est pas la faute aux
intellectuels je ne sais pas la faute à
qui il faudrait peut d'ailleurs posé la
question
enfin c'est pas la faute des
intellectuels si on a voté le pen et
maigret à 19 ou 20 % dimanche dernier
alors dans le bloc notes du point cette
semaine vous dit pour la première fois
depuis trente ans que je vote je vais
voter chirac alors comme du canard
enchaîné entre l'escroc elle fachos vous
choisissez l'escroc oui surtout que le
facho est aussi un est aussi un escroc
s'intéresse on s'intéresse beaucoup aux
finances du rpr du parti socialiste on a
raison c'est très bien bizarrement
s'intéresse pas aux finances du front
national il ya des gens qui l'ont fait
connaître ni qui dans les filières noir
a review et ses essais des finances pour
y aller le front national c'est a été le
pen a été mêlé toute sa vie à des
trafiquants notoires à des gens qui ont
fait de la prison comme comme laurent
mirabeau et comme et comme d'autres il
ya un système de captation d'héritage
par exemple au front au front national
un système de captation d'héritage au
profit du chef pas au profit du parti
parce que la loi française interdit au
profit du chef lui-même le pen qui
depuis l'histoire de cet héritier d'une
cimenterie qui s'appelait lambert je
crois qu'ils étaient qui avait quelques
petits problèmes qui a fait la fortune
de le pen en lui léguant sa fortune il y
en a eu d'autres depuis
alors
le facho est aussi un escroc en gros ce
que je crois moi c'est que il faut
transformer dimanche prochain le second
tour de la présidentielle
faut le transformer en autre chose on a
un référendum pour la démocratie
un référendum pas tellement contre le
pen pour la démocratie pour les valeurs
républicaines pour effacer cette espèce
de d'horreur et de honte et de
saloperies qui s'est passé dimanche
dernier
et pour ça en effet il faut qu'il y ait
90 % et vous savez bien d'ailleurs plus
on vote on sera nombreux à voter pour
chirac - ce sera votre chirac à 65% ça
sera un vote pour chirac à 90% à 95%
nous on ne verra bien que c'est pas un
vote pour chirac donc soyons très très
nombreux à voter pour chirac parce que
d'une certaine manière c'est le meilleur
moyen de ne pas voter pour lui
bah bien
je vais vous dire je me sens vraiment
responsable et je suis vert de ce qui
s'est passé dimanche parce que je fais
partie des gens qui n'ont pas été votées
et je suis me rends compte mois les
beautés du monde
moi je suis allé voter
watt soit on dirait que je suis sûr
qu'il s'en fout le plus étoilé moi je
suis allé voter dimanche
non mais c'est vrai que c'est de notre
faute c'est de ma faute je me sens
responsable mais je peux vous dire qu'on
s'est appelée avec nos potes derrière
pour se dire là ce qu'on est en train de
voir
c'est de notre faute c'est de ma faute
c'est et effectivement je pense que plus
que jamais enfin personnellement c'est
la dernière fois de ma vie que je ne
vote pas aussi pour sa part
on s'est battu pour avoir ce droit le
droit de vote et parce qu'on est des
désillusionnés de la politique ou parce
que ce week-end là on avait autre chose
à faire on a on est passé à autre chose
c'est de toute façon on était tellement
persuadé que j'ose pas sera en face de
chirac
voilà et là c'est vraiment moi je me
sens je me sens merdique depuis depuis
dimanche dernier parce que je fais
partie des responsables vous trouvez
normal qu'ils aient pas eu de débat
entre chirac et le pen oui bien sûr bien
sûr que oui
attendez le pen a tout la possibilité de
s'adresser
ça c'est les règles démocratiques et
c'est bien il s'adresse à l'électorat y
vend sa salade yvan son programme avec
des temps de parole etc
mais mettre sur le même plan la parole
d'un fasciste la fasciste qui
connaissent que ça c'est toute la
question aussi on se pose souvent la
question de savoir est ce que les gens
qui ont voté le pen sont tous des
fascistes évidemment non mais ce qu'ils
ont voté pour associer évidemment
curieuse utilisé est-ce que les peines
et cela parce que le pen est un fasciste
évidemment oui et il est à fasciste dans
toutes les fibres de son histoire
il a fondé le front national avec des
anciens nazis vous le savez ça des
waffen ss des gens qui s'étaient battus
sous uniforme allemand des gens qui
avaient suivi les qui ont été condamnées
à la libération pour haute trahison et
intelligence avec l'ennemi
il a fabriqué le front national avec ça
donc c'est un authentique fasciste
parfait mais est ce que un démocrate et
un républicain a doit mettre sa parole
au même niveau que celle d'un
authentique fasciste je crois que non et
donc je crois que la décision de chirac
de ne pas faire ce débat est une bonne
décision
alors justement effectivement l'huile
est ce qu'il est mais les gens qui ont
voté pour lui c'est souvent des gens qui
ont utilisé le vote le pen pour dire
quelque chose pour se plaindre des gens
qui sont malheureuses et jean moi je
vois argentan où j'habite les gens de
moulinex qui sont la région on leur fait
maintenant des saisies arrêt sur chômage
c'est à dire que c'est incroyable ils
sont au chômage non leur saisie quand
même une partie de leur chômage c'est un
moment qu'elle août solution rien la
première solution qui aurait eu et ce à
la gauche a une vraie responsabilité
elle nous parle depuis des années
de l'annulation de la dette du
tiers-monde pourquoi elle nous parlait
pas de l'annulation de la dette du quart
monde
c'est à dire ça le gars d'argentan a qui
ont saisi son allocation chômage c'est
aussi bouleversant et ça mérite autant
la compassion et les et l'esprit
réformiste que le mali ou que le burkina
faso alors qu'il a ou que l'afghanistan
donc là il ya une vraie responsabilité
de la gauche qui a été en effet au
dessous de tout mais moi je crois qu'il
faut justement dire à ces gens là qu'ils
ont été abusés qu'ils ont été floués
qu'ils ne savent pas pour quel parti ils
ont voté par exemple il ya des
gaullistes qui ont voté le pen est ce
qu'ils savent que le pen est quelqu'un
qui faisait partie dans les airs au
début des années 60 des gens qui
voulaient tuer le général de gaulle est
ce qu'ils savent vous savez l'homme qui
a tiré sur de gaulle qui s'appelait
bastien thiry petit clamart petit
l'attentât du petit-clamart jean marie
le pen a fait c'est pas de l'histoire
c'est pas de la campagne c'est pas de la
campagne électorale c'est une histoire
ça on est dans l'histoire de france
le pen a fait l'éloge de cet homme là il
a dit qu'il était l'honneur de la france
il a dit que c'était être l'honneur de
la france que d'avoir tiré sur l'homme
du 18 juin
or ça il faut le dire aux gens qui se
réclament du gaullisme et qui ont voté
pour le pet
donc ça il faut le dire aux gens ils ont
été abusés par un démagogue par un
histrion par un parent un homme très
habile très éloquent qui les a flouées
bernard le pen père dimanche prochain
qui va s'occuper des gens d'argentan a
qui ont saisi leurs allocations chômage
je sais pas qui va s'en occuper mais y'a
intérêt à le faire parce qu'on ait fait
ça c'est à ce qui s'est passé là est un
est un vrai signal est un vrai
avertissement et le prochain président
donc jacques chirac s'il ne prend pas la
mesure de sa s'il ne prend pas la mesure
de la fracture morale et de la fracture
sociale qui aujourd'hui divise la france
je crois qu'il va au devant de terribles
déconvenues et les gars et les et les
les jeunes gens et les et les moins
jeunes qui sont dans la rue aujourd'hui
savaient ils vont pas rentrer si
facilement dans l'est dans les dortoirs
des pensions dans les lycées et dans
l'eure
dans leur maison ils demanderont des
comptes au prochain président et il est
en train de se passer d'ailleurs
aujourd'hui quelque chose d'assez
extraordinaire
à toute chose malheur est bon peut-être
mais enfin dans à cette espèce de 2,2
d'ignominies qui s'est produit dimanche
dernier répond quelque chose d'assez
beau cette mobilisation cette prise de
conscience ces jeunes gens qui disent
comme nadia tout à l'heure parce que ce
que vous disiez c'est ce que je n'arrête
pas d'entendre
pourquoi est-ce que je n'ai pas voté je
m'en veux c'est ma faute
on ne m'y reprendra plus ça s'appelle
une à un sursaut citoyen alors le
prochain président j'espère qu'il sera à
la hauteur de ça parce qu'il aura à
faire face à ce sursaut citoyen qui est
en train de se produire dans notre pays
est ce qu'il à la grandeur d'être à la
hauteur on verra moi je ne fais pas de
je ne fais pas de procès d'intention
ce que je vous disais sur le pen tout à
l'heure c'est pas du procès d'intention
c'est de l'histoire c'est l'effet est
sûre chirac je fais pas de procès
d'intention
on verra j'espère pour lui et j'espère
surtout pour nous parce que s'il n'est
pas à la hauteur de sa alors vraiment je
crois qu'on est mal
voilà
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
alors et lévis vous êtes mûr pour une
interview de technicolor
[Musique]
les gars
qu'est ce qui vous rend vert de rage
pour rester sur le registre ce que nous
disions ce qui me rend vers de rage
s'est laissé les bobos qui ont voté
laguiller besancenot premier tour parce
que qu'un qu'un syndicaliste qu'un
employé du crédit lyonnais qui gagne 12
mille balles par mois votre laguiller je
comprends qu'un postier vote besancenot
je comprends mais que des bourgeois fric
et j'en connais plein autour de moi
votre laguiller parce qu'il a trouvé
mouvante et votre besancenot parce qu'il
le trouve sympa ça je trouve ça nul et
on n'en serait pas là où nous sommes
jospin serait au second tour s'il n'y
avait pas eu ça donc ça c'est vrai que
ça me rend vers d'orge qu'est ce qui
vous rend rouge de honte là la presse
internationale la presse étrangère
depuis dimanche dernier c'est à dire le
spectacle que nous donnons la le fait
que nous soyons la risée du monde entier
ont donné des leçons aux autrichiens
cause de hyder ont donné des leçons à
aux italiens à cause à cause de
berlusconi et on se retrouve avec le
pire des trois ingrédients le pet et le
pire pourquoi hein parce que c'est le
plus fashion et deux parce que c'est le
plus gros test
parce qu'en plus il est plus ridicule
donc ça en effet ça me rend comment vu
rouge de rôle de rampe
qu'est ce qui vous rend bleus de peur
c'est que le front national on verra son
score mais qu'ils n'en produisent en
france le sale venin de la haine de la
violence et de la guerre civile parce
que ça aussi je crois qu'il faut le dire
aux gens qui nous écoutent le il se
présente sous le drapeau de la lutte
contre l'insécurité partout ils sont
allés dans toutes les mairies qu'ils ont
géré ils ont pas eu moins d'insécurité
ils ont eu plus d'insécurité ils ont mis
en place des milices privées moi je me
rappelle à vitrolles j'étais allé avec
konopnicki on avait fait un film à
vitrolles qui s'appelait bienvenue à
vitrolles et on avait vu par exemple se
mettre en place le dps qui est une
milice privée d'une milice privée du
front national une police parallèle et
ce à la police parallèle en france quand
c'est vitrolles c'est déjà très grave
mais si ça devait venir si le front
national fort de son succès se croyant
tout permis venait à multiplier ce genre
de choses alors là je crois que nous
serions au bord de troubles très grave
de grande violence à val fourré comme
vous disiez tout à l'heure et ailleurs
et ça c'est vrai que ça me fout les
jetons
cette espèce de culture de la haine que
le front national est en train
d'introduire en france
ce qui vous rend rose de bonheur ce qui
me rendrait ans de bonheur ses 6 et 10%
dimanche prochain c'est à dire si je
suis là on sait même plus à ariel là je
suis légèrement obsédé way et il faut
que le pen retourne dans sa boîte un son
score en france c'est 10% ces 15%
c'est pas plus il faut qu'ils retournent
au 10 ou 15% et là bas on serait tous
heureux on fera ce qui vous fait rire
jaune
quand je vois comme l'autre jour chez
séguillon le pen qui se drape dans le
drapeau de la france et de la république
alors que c'est le contraire
par exemple voilà l'amour de la france
moi je crois que le front national c'est
le front antinational c'est à dire
chaque fois qu'il y a dans le monde
un parti un groupe qui est la france
le pen s'y rallient par exemple en
belgique est un parti qui s'appelle le
vlaams blok le vlaams blok ya des trucs
qui fait c'est qu'à la frontière entre
la belgique et la france en flandre il
supprime les panneaux français il
supprime lille
les panneaux de signalisation bon c'est
un ballast un parti anti français c'est
l'allié de le pen c'est avec ça qu'ils
fait cause commune au parlement européen
alors tout ça
quand j'entends dire que le pen est un
et aime la france par exemple
ça me fait rire et ça me fait rire très
jaune j'en aurais dit bonsoir on parle
de votre vie vous êtes dans tout le
monde en parle c'est normal le livre
s'appelle qui a tué daniel pearl et
c'est édité chez grasset
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qui a tué daniel pearl donc un titre de
polars pour un livre qui mêle enquête
journalistique
le témoignage historique la réflexion
philosophique
alors on va commencer par le
commencement avant de savoir qui a tué
daniel pearl on va se demander qui était
daniel pearl flux d'infos grand reporter
ou l street journal c'est ça oui grand
grand journaliste maniaque de la vérité
grands américains ouverts au monde
curieux du monde il ya l'amérique des
faucons de george bush et il y à
l'amérique de daniel pearl
c'était une sorte de juste qu'ils
voulaient qu'ils étaient au pakistan
parce qu'il voulait comprendre il
voulait connaître le mal il voulait
approcher au plus près d'eux des
barbarie contemporaine alors pearl a été
enlevé à karachi le 23 janvier 2002
assassiné une semaine plus tard et son
supplice a été filmée par un par ses
bourreaux daniel pearl a été a été
assassiné si j'ose dire en direct
c'est un cas assez inédit je trouve dans
l'histoire des barbaries il y à des
assassins qui cachent leurs crimes
les nazis
considérer leurs propres crimes comme un
coma terrifiant secret qu'il fallait
dont il fallait effacer les traces
les islamistes qui décapitaient daniel
pearl au contraire veulent l'exhiber
veulent le montrer
et dans cette vidéo qui les ont prises
et qui est un document terrible que j'ai
que j'ai vu et revu
trop d'ailleurs peut-être là l'image le
film se termine par l'image d'une main
qui brandit la tête décapitée de daniel
pearl sanguinolentes et est décapité et
puis on ne tue pas n'importe comment on
le tue après lui avoir fait dire devant
la caméra
je suis juif mon père est juif ma mère
est juive
j'appartiens à une famille sionisme l'un
de nos aïeux haïm père avait donné son
nom à une rude dans un petit village
près de près de tel aviv
et pour moi cette image c'est vrai que
lorsque gelé lorsque j'ai vu pour la
première fois j'ai tout de suite senti
qu'elle était qu'elle était
bouleversante qu'elle était peut-être
aussi importante dans ce début de xxième
siècle que l'image des détours brisé des
tours détruites du world trade center
alors la vidéo diffusée sur internet et
vous dites dans votre bouquin qu'elle
est vendue au pakistan à la porte de
certaines mosquées comme un instrument
de propagande
oui c'est comme ça que je les mois je
n'ai pas trouvé sur internet je les
trouvais au pakistan je les achetais
dans une mosquée à la porte d'une
mosquée de karachi sous le manteau ou
mais ça ne trompait personne est en
effet ceux qui me l'ont pour ceux qui me
l'ont vendu ça n'est pas ce crime n'est
pas un crime honteux c'est un crime dont
se prévaut c'est un crime que l'on porte
en bandoulière c'est un crime qui est
supposé faire gloire à dieu c'est c'est
posséder là c'est ce que je dis à un
moment donné du livre et c'est une chose
qui m'a qui m'a beaucoup frappé moi je
suis comme tous les occidentaux je suis
habitué à une définition du nihilisme
très occidentale le nihiliste posséder
c'est celui qui croit que tout est
permis
parce que dieu n'existe plus cela
lorsque tout est permis
parce que dieu existe y compris des
coupes et égorgé un homme un juif le
découper en dix morceaux
recomposé ces dix morceaux les bras les
jambes coupées allen le trou en la tête
les pieds pour l'enterrer et une fois
enterré diffuser cette cassette dans
l'est dans les madrassas et les et les
mosquées donc c'est là en effet que je
les trouvais alors pearl a été tué parce
qu'ils étaient américains parce qu'ils
étaient journalistes parce qu'il était
juif vous venez de le dire mais surtout
je dirais parce qu'il était sur le point
de découvrir des choses très graves on
va voir quoi et c'est là où vous
reprenez vous bernard henri lévy
l'enquète de daniel pearl
là où il l'avait laissé une enquête qui
va durer un an et qui va vous mener à
karachi à londres à new delhi à
washington en bosnie en californie une
enquête que l'on suit dans votre dans
votre bouquin jour après jour une
enquête dangereuse parce que finalement
contrairement à ce que vous dites aux
autorités pakistanaises en arrivant à
karachi
c'est pas la première fois que vous
venez au pakistan puisque ça a été votre
votre premier livre en 71 à l'époque du
bangladesh quand le pakistan oriental
s'est séparé du du pakistan occidental
et puis vous êtes juif faut être cinglé
non je sais pas vous savez c'était
dangereux oui peut-être mais j'étais
instruit par le précédent de peur je
savais les pièges dans lesquels il ne
fallait pas tomber
je savais celui où il était tombé lui
même et voilà et pour moi c'était je ne
sais pas comment vous dire j'ai passé
sept années dans un dans un drôle d'état
jeu je pensais qu'il fallait faire ça
c'était ça mon idée mon obsession mamoun
idée fixe
je voulais finir l'article inachevé de
daniel peur cet homme qui en même temps
jusqu'à la dernière minute essayer de
comprendre qui il avait en face de lui
c'est une des choses aussi qui maquille
matin tellement impressionné jusque dans
cette dans ce lieu de son supplice où je
suis allé parce que je vous avais
effectivement jusqu'à là ce que vous
appelez la maison du supplice l'endroit
où pearl a été assassiné sur était
révolue j'ai voulu le faire c'était pour
moi très important
j'ai voulu retrouver tous les lieux les
lieux où ces assassins se sont réunis
les lieux où ils ont passé leur dernière
nuit
liu il a été enlevé et plus le lieu où
il a été séquestré dans les faubourgs de
karachi à l'extrême limite de la ville
une petite maison dans un jardin de
manguiers et d'acacias cachée de la rue
et des regards extérieurs une maison
totalement désolé avec des convois de
fourmi rouge avec un sol humide avec une
sorte d' innovation permanente qui vient
dé des écoulements d'eau du dehors un
lit de cordes qui est toujours là qui
était le lit de daniel pearl et où il a
passé ses six jours dans des conditions
donc épouvantable avec la mort qui
l'attendait au bout de ce rendez vous et
ce qui est extraordinaire c'est que
jusque dans ces circonstances là il
faisait son métier il était en face
d'eux et ils voulaient comprendre qu'est
ce qu'ils avaient dans la tête pourquoi
ces hommes là le haïssent et et nous
haïssent et qu'est ce que c'était cannes
islamiste radicale comment l'islam qui
est une belle religion pouvait connaître
ce dévoiement parce que daniel pearl
c'est aussi une chose moi qui m'a qui
m'a attaché visera voilà et qui fait que
j'ai vécu dans sa compagnie pendant
pendant tous ces mois c'est que c'était
un type tout de même bizarre qui
pensaient que qui se sentait proche de
ses adversaires qui ne les stigmatiser
pas qu'ils allaient vers l'autre et qui
jusque dans ces conditions extrêmes donc
jusque dans sa geôle n'avait qu'une
obsession savoir ce qu'ils avaient dans
le crâne probablement jusqu'à la
dernière seconde je crois qu'au moment
où on l'amène en tout cas dans la
deuxième cellule celle où on va
l'exécuter quand il voit autour de lui
les six pakistanais qu'ils attendent les
trois yéménites dans un coin qui ont
déjà le grand couteau recourbé à moitié
sorti du four au celui qui va le tuer
lorsqu'il voit la petite petit caméscope
qu'il prend d'abord pour un fusil qui va
le tuer à bout portant est dit on il
comprend ensuite que c'est une vidéo
je crois que jusqu'à cette dernière
minute là jusqu'au moment où où certains
de ceux la sorte pour laisser la place
aux yéménites qui vont procéder à
l'exécution
il y croisera il croit qu'il est encore
en présence d'un groupe d'islamistes
dont il va essayer de comprendre les
motivations et les ressorts alors dans
votre bouquin et à ce personnage donc de
daniel pearl ce journaliste il ya un
autre personnage qui était très
fascinant aussi même si même s'il
incarne
le mal c'est le dénommé omar omar sheikh
le cerveau de l'assassinât de daniel
pearl qu'ils en fait anglais omar sheikh
donc cet assassin ce type qui a tout
organisé et qui a constitué autour de ce
crime tout un tout un syndicat qui a
rassemblé toutes les composantes de la
mouvance islamiste pakistanaise donc un
personnage épouvantable or c'est vrai
qu'il est des nôtres
c'est vrai qu'il est anglais pas anglais
anglais parfait élevée dans les
meilleures écoles elles veulent une
london school avec le lendemain ce qui
est un peu l'ena britannique
il sort de cette école il appartient à
une famille de bourgeois les parents le
voyait comme un futur grand d'angleterre
comme un fou dans l'ordre alors bernard
pourquoi ce basculement pourquoi des
gens justement comme ben laden comme
mohammed atta comme omar cher comment
des gens comme ça peuvent basculer j'ai
quelques hypothèses dans ce livre
l'obsession de la pureté un certain
rapport à la sexualité au corps féminin
au marché qui est un personnage qui est
vierge à 30 ans c'est quelqu'un qui est
qui aime l'équipe qui est intéressé par
les filles qui probablement les
intéresse qui équipe qui est beau gosse
qui a qui est quelqu'un d'extrêmement
brillant cultivé etc
et il a une espèce d'effroi de peur
panique du corps et du sexe féminin et
il dit à un moment donné moi je retrouve
en espagne dans un petit village
espagnol dans l'avenue perché dans les
montagnes du nord de l'espagne
un gars espèce de vieux rocker anglais
qui s'appelle péter rôji qui est un qui
avait fait quelques années prison à new
delhi pour trafic de mauvaises de
mauvais chocolat blanc et qui a passé
huit mois huit mois dans la même cellule
que omar sheikh
ils ont été compagnon de cellule et
petter jim me dis que des nuits entières
y parlait notamment de sa les femmes et
aux marchés que lui disait au fond tu
vois il était déjà devenu terroriste il
avait déjà basculé dans l'horreur
le vrai courage c'est pas d'avoir peur
de la mort je n'en ai pas peur c'est pas
de se mettre d une ceinture d'explosifs
et d'aller se faire sauter contre un
char
indiens ou contraint un soldat israélien
non le vrai courage
ç'aurait été lorsque j'étais à la london
school of economics d'inviter la petite
sarah dont j'étais secrètement des prix
et l'invité à boire un café
alors bernard vous découvrez donc cette
omar sheikh est liée aux services
secrets pakistanais et finalement
l'assassinât de daniel pearl n'est pas
un simple assassinats commis par une
bande de terroristes islamistes c'est un
crime d'état ça me semblait tellement
fou qu'un état tout entier se mobilise
et mobilise ses forces de mort pour
exécuter un simple individu que j'ai
tardé à l'admettre et je crois
malheureusement que les preuves que je
produis sont accablantes
il a été au marché qui était un agent
des services secrets pakistanais
et c'est sur ordre de ses supérieurs
qu'il a assassiné ou organisé
l'assassinât de daniel pearl
hélas alors là ce que ce que vous
racontez donne le vertige
on s'aperçoit effectivement que le le
patron du pakistan le président du
pakistan c'est à dire musharraf ne ne
contrôle pas du tout son pays puisque
huit jours après la mort de daniel pearl
il est aux usa il est à washington et on
lui demande s'il pense retrouver peur
donc les jours après la mort et il dit
oui dans quelques jours je l'espère on
se rend compte que ce pakistan en fait
n'est pas tenue c'est à dire que on a
des chars avec un type qui qui qui tient
pas son pays on voit bien d'ailleurs
quand vous allez dans une une mosquée
qui s'appelle bino reetone qui est
l'endroit où ben laden a sans doute été
soigné après son départ de dagany ce
temps il ya un hôpital il ya un sur
d'enregistrement c'est 1 500 mètres du
consulat des états unis
et si une base terroriste quoi c'est
probablement la base d'où partent les
autres fassent de la base oui la base de
la base sur la base de laquelle il a
absolument le repère absolu l'endroit où
ben laden va se faire soigner been
written ça il faut se figurer ce que
c'est c'est une c'est un lieu saint
c'est une mosquée donc un lieu de piété
ou vous rencontrez des gens en armes des
mollahs en armes où vous voyez des
placards des dépôts retraits dans un
lieu qui l'imposé interdire la
représentation des portraits de ben
laden
et tout ça en effet au coeur de karachi
au coeur d'une capitale d'un pays
posez être allié des états unis et là
vous découvrez en fait la proximité
complète qui existe entre al qaïda et le
pakistan l'implication d'omar chèque
dans les attentats du 11 septembre la
bienvenue après les 11 septembre
d'ailleurs comme le pakistan n'était pas
tenue du tout puisque il arrivait à
peine à contenir les révoltes et l'autre
sur les débuts du collège bien sûr vous
avez absolument raison mais là ne pas
parvenir à kuala à tenir des à contenir
des révoltes et une chose donné l'ordre
d'envoyer de l'argent à mohammed atta
qui est une des choses que j'ai il pas
d'un jour produit dans le livre une
désinformation que j'apporte dans le
livre en est une autre
moi je crois aujourd'hui que le pakistan
est un allié des états unis
membres de la coalition antiterroriste
fait partie des états bailleurs de fond
de l'attentât du 11 septembre
autrement dit c'est là c'est la
citadelle c'est le centre nerveux c'est
le coeur de la galaxie al qaïda alors ce
homard et des ben laden à mettre de
l'ordre dans ses finances
et là effectivement ce que vous dites
c'est assez évident mais on n'y pense
pas obligatoirement c'est vrai que ben
laden arrive toujours les gens comme lui
a été long à se faire passer pour des
gens extrêmement désintéressé ben laden
c'est comme le pen c'est comme le pen
savait que le pen quand on veut être
candidat
aux élections vous payez il faut payer
le chef don mais il faut payer le loyer
de du château de saint-cloud ben laden
c'est pareil
tout le système est organisé comme un
système d'extorsion de fond une mafia un
gang alors extorsion de 2,2 le trafic de
drogue trafic alors ces hommes qui se
prétendent porteur d'un islam pur trafic
de filles de vierges de conférences qui
sont livrés aux emmy à tel ou tel émir
de tel ou tel émirats trafic de matières
diverses trafic de fausses cartes de
crédit spéculation boursière très
sophistiqué parce que sur les attentats
du 11 septembre il avait acheté des
actions puisqu'il savait la date a
évidemment il savait la date et les
d'initié délit d'initié puissance pile
on a l'idée on se dit ben laden c'est
une crapule etc
enfin au moins il y croise au moins
c'est un ascète qui vit dans sa grotte
dans son désert dans son tora bora et
qui fait don de sa fortune à la cause de
la solution c'est le contraire c'est un
mec qui fait du fric c'est un type qui
vit probablement dans un mois j'ai
visité la maison de mollah omar
la marque était son complice à kandahar
le patron des talibans
j'ai visité sa maison la maison de cet
homme qu'on imaginait là encore comme un
modèle de piété c'est un lupanar une
maison d'un luxe extraordinaire horrible
d'ailleurs d'un kitsch rapidement taillé
comme chez sara hussein ne sais pas te
dire que saddam hussein pire que saddam
hussein des roses criard des scènes de
vie au paradis des hammams des saunas
des jacuzzis des des choses
hallucinantes
ce sont des gens pour qui le gie à 10
mhz l'intégrisme musulman c'est une
manière d'acquérir du pouvoir et de
l'argent
c'est une aiguille une économie une
source de prestige
on voit bien moi j'ai rencontre j'ai
retrouvé des gens qui étaient des
voisins d'omar à lahore est il le voit
revenir après son premier séjour en
prison en inde
ils le voient arriver à lahore il jouit
d'un prestige extraordinaire il vient il
a enlevé des touristes anglais il a
procédé ou assister à la décapitation en
déjà avant daniel pearl d'un jeune
indien
mais il est un héros il roule en cas de
4 il a des amis prestigieux il est
invité dans toutes les grandes soirées
organisées par les officiels pakistanais
le terrorisme comme ascenseur social
lorsqu'on apprend aussi en lisant votre
bouquin c'est
ben laden on le prend toujours pour le
sommet de la pyramide pour le chef
suprême
en fait il a des maîtres il a des
maîtres et si pearl a été assassiné
c'est aussi parce qu'il était sur la
piste d'un dénommé ghillani qui est un
peu le parent du parrain un peu le
parrain de ben laden et lui pareil c'est
un mec qui vient des usa pearl a
véritablement levé le lièvre ce
personnage pire mubarik shah geelani
était totalement inconnu il y avait eu
un premier article qui était paru dans
le boston globe et quelques jours après
pearl se met sur la piste et de manière
obsessionnelle et c'est ça qu'il faisait
le jour où il a été enlevé on venait le
chercher pour l'emmener se gère comme
monsieur gérard en fait veut l'amener
chez ghillani aux états ils de démarrer
sens il a un il donnerait tout rentrer
le lendemain aux et aux etats unis son
reportage est terminé son billet d'avion
est pris il a une fin une fête d'adieu
qui est organisée pour lui le soir même
sa femme marianne est enceint qu'ils
attendent un petit garçon qui est née
aujourd'hui maintenant il ya quelques
mois et son dernier rendez vous et ce il
donnerait tout et il a donné sa vie pour
ce rendez vous c'est pour aller voir ce
qu'il a nié parce que qui est ce
ghillani moi j'ai là encore j'ai pas
fait grand chose je me suis remis dans
les pas de pearl
j'ai essayé de tirer complètement le fil
qu'il avait commencé de tirer et je
découvre quoi un que c'est en effet le
maître secret de ben laden ben laden
c'est un c'est un bon financier c'est
peut-être un bon stratège c'est un bon
public relations et d'al qaïda mais
c'est pas un idéologue c'est pas un
maître spirituel et il a derrière lui
des maîtres spirituels qui sont un peu
c'est souffleur ghillani c'est le
souffleur de ben laden
ça c'est la première chose qu'ils
avaient pressenti peur et que je crois
je démontre deuxièmement ghillani c'est
quelqu'un qui fait dont l'organisation
elle est à cheval en effet et ça c'est
extrêmement troublant à cheval entre le
pakistan et les états unis sa secte
s'appelle la sec
elle fut créée elle a une filiale aux
états unis qui s'appelle muslim show of
america laquelle muslims of america
organise
à achètent des centaines d'hectares dans
des comptes et peu peuplé des états unis
dans le dos la war dans le colorado
ailleurs près de san francisco aussi et
organise la des espèces de petites
communautés désenclaver désenclave
vivant selon les règles d'un islam pur
portant au fronton j'ai visité l'un de
ces villages et on voit c'est une
atmosphère de western
il ya des pionniers il ya des roulottes
il ya la roulotte de la mosquée il ya la
roulotte de la boulangerie il ya
plusieurs roulottes en cercles qui
forment l'école des grands et puis
l'école des petits plus en plus en dur
et vous avez là des communautés
villageoises qui sont supposés dont tout
un côté retour à la terre quitté les
villes du démon quitter les les
l'esprit de corruption de l'occident de
kwajalein musulmans quoi les couacs
heurts musulmans reconstituant une
espèce de pureté à l'intérieur même du
corps de l'ennemi ghillani c'est ça et
ça c'est la deuxième chose que pearl
était je crois en train de la troisième
chose la troisième chose que pearl était
en train de découvrir c'est la bombe
nucléaire pakistanaise mais ce que vous
dites dans votre bouquin et c'est assez
logique c'est qu'en fait cette bombe
pakistanaise n'est pas vraiment
pakistanaise c'est la bombe islamique
c'est la bombe de l'oumma parce que les
savants vous dit le oppenheimer
pakistanais l'inventeur de la bombe
atomique pakistanaise
en fait il est tellement proche des
djihadistes des islamistes purs et durs
qu'en fait la bombe appartient à eux je
retrouve la piste d'un type qui
s'appelle abdul qadeer khan qui est en
effet le patron du commissariat à
l'énergie atomique pakistanais est
l'inventeur de la bombe islamique
et là encore plusieurs choses d'abord le
type c'est un vrai islamistes il est il
appartient à une organisation le lashkar
e taïba qui est une des organisations
djihadistes les plus cruels et plus
barbares mêlé à l'assassinât de pearl
il en est l'une des figures marquantes
deuxièmement c'est une homme
extraordinairement populaire dans les
manifestations dont vous parliez tout à
l'heure
ces manifestations de jia d'ist anti
américaine anti bush a ralenti tout ça
il ya des portraits
et d'abdul qadeer khan en tête il ya des
portraits d'une des missiles pakistanais
c'est le seul pays au monde où on voit
en tête des manifs des banderoles où des
pancartes où on voit les ddd des dessins
naïfs des missiles pakistanais c'est le
seul pays au monde où l'armé nucléaire
est une grande cause nationale est une
grande cause religieuse et chaque fois
qu'il y à des tentatives de la part des
états unis bien sûr mais même de la
communauté internationale d'obliger le
pakistan à respecter le pacte de non
prolifération nucléaire
vous avez des manifs terrible dans la
rue sur le thème vous êtes en train de
brader l'honneur national du pakistan la
bombe n'appartient pas aux militaires
pakistanais elle appartient au peuple de
dieu et elle appartient d'accessoires
musulmane d'un tiers est ce que peur
découvre c'est qu'il y a depuis
plusieurs mois des contacts en effet
étroits entre ces hommes là ma double
qadeer khan et d'autres mahmoud
et puis ben laden autrefois les talibans
maintenant ben laden et les coréens du
nord
donc vous avez ici un état pakistan qui
n'a pas que vous disiez casile armes
nucléaires non c'est un état nucléaire
il a la bombe atomique il a il est doté
d'armes de destruction massive et ses
armes de destruction massive sa doctrine
officielle aujourd'hui c'est qu'elle
doive proliférer c'est qu'elles doivent
aller sous forme de bombe sale ou de
bombes miniaturisés dans les mains d
les assassins qui croient à la guerre
des civilisations
contrairement à daniel pearl où
contrairement à nous j'accueille
maintenant bernard henri lévy
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les biberons soir moi j'ai un désaccord
majeur avec baffie ce soir c'est quoi
c'est il a froid et que je meurs de
chaux et fait chaud mais fait une
chaleur de bêtes dans la boutique qui a
froid tu fait rempart de ton corps là tu
vas le lot chercher une petite laine tu
ne touches pas à l'air conditionné bon
bernard bonsoir bonsoir donc invité pour
un volume de 1000 pages intitulé
récidive recueil de textes souvent
inédits sur des sujets très divers la
littérature la philosophie
le cinéma le théâtre mais aussi votre
judéité le fascisme la guerre l'amitié
en fait c'est assez éclectique et
brillant on comprend que votre facilité
énerve beaucoup de monde quand on lit ce
bouquin je sais pas avec l'éthique non
scellées c'est mon travail voilà c'est
les quatre ou cinq dernières années de
travail sur en effet des registres
divers
donc voilà on dit parfois que les
intellectuels qui vont un peu trop à la
télévision ne travaille pas c'est ce
livre là c'est la preuve du contraire
mais vraiment qu'est ce qui se passe
lors rien continue à tirer à ce jour
c'est mon blouson on est là
[Applaudissements]
donc difficile de reprocher notamment
bernard-henri lévy on vous reproche
votre argent vous êtes riche
je ne sais pas il ya un bug y paraît les
oreilles en france en france un
intellectuel qui a les moyens disons
c'est moins bien vu que les états unis
écoutez d'abord en france qu'il y à des
écrivains qui ont eu un peu d'argent
c'est arrivé andré gide
avec cette réputation il était valery
larbaud michel leiris raymond roussel
c'est pas une chose complètement anormal
plus en france non ça dépend ce qu'on en
fait ça dépend voilà il est écrit quoi
valery larbaud s'il a échappé compris
l'a écrit notamment un livre que vous
auriez avantage à lire qui s'appelle le
journal de barna boot2 etc est un très
beau livre d'anna butzbach galerie pour
je me ridiculiser libraires bonjour on
aboutit en tout cas ce soir avant le
libraire chez leur dise oh oh oh th à la
fin bien
non mais vous êtes en plus discret sur
l'utilisation vous fait de cet argent je
faisais jamais dit que vous avez créé
une fondation qui s'appelle du nom de
votre père andré lévy que vous financez
par exemple à un journal à kaboul qui
s'appelle les nouvelles de kaboul non
c'est vrai oui que j'ai créé à la
mémoire de mon père une petite fondation
wiki qui finance ce journal à kaboul qui
finance une radio en afrique au burundi
ça c'est un projet auquel je tiens
beaucoup
avec le cheval de bronze n'est le
génocide du rwanda il commencé bujumbura
bujumbura
sébastien michon c'est presque ça car
d'abord ces deux pays jumeaux au rwanda
le génocide a eu lieu au burundi il est
en train d'avoir lieu
il a eu au rwanda comme vous le savez à
partir et d'où votre erreur à partir de
radio c'est la fameuse radio mille
collines voilà qui a lancé les appels au
meurtre et qui a chauffé à blanc les
assassins et c'est ce qui est en train
de se préparer au burundi et en effet la
fondation donc que dont je m'occupe
créer une radio alternative une radio de
la démocratie une radio de la paix une
radio contre le meurtre et contre
l'appel au crime voilà donc ça vous le
dites pas finalement
pour moi l'essentiel de l'essentiel de
ma vie
et il est dans les livres il est
d'ailleurs donc je préfère en effet
qu'on parle de de la littérature
on va parler de livres parce que votre
vie bernard lévy suscite quand même pas
mal de curiosité
il ya trois livres en préparation sur
vous 3,3 biographie non autorisée et
j'imagine non à totalement non motorisés
ouais mais ça c'est la sas et c'est
l'habitude maintenant où ses lacets la
manie cd des livres de flics et de
délation l'auteur d'un de ses livres
c'est pas d'auteur abstrait il s'appelle
philippe cohen c'est l'homme qui a écrit
avec p ans se livrent dégueulasse contre
le monde
ce livre où on allait chercher d d d d
histoire sur le passé des pères afin de
confondre les fils se devront de lise et
noir sur blanc comme dans la presse
d'extrême droite des années 30 que le
monde c'était le journal de l'anti
france donc c'est l'auteur de ce livre
là sur vaud a eu l'idée saugrenue voilà
d'aller fouiller dans ma dans ma vie
dans mon passé dans mon présente ses
draps et de raconter ma biographie est
en effet c'est totalement non autorisée
je trouve cette idée détestable et je
trouve que les voilà c'est pas sur le
terrifiant de savoir qu'il ya trois
personnes qui passent leur temps à
essayer de trouver des secrets sur vous
c'est extrêmement désagréable c'est un
peu vous savez c on a l'impression d'une
sorte de vol de vos tours 1 et c'est
assez curieux alors je reçois des coups
de téléphone des coups de téléphone
d'amis qui m'alerte des coups de
téléphone d'anciens amis qui se
souviennent des coups de téléphone
d'ennemis qui peut en une espèce de
dernier réflexe d'élégance et qui me
disent j'ai reçu un appel de philippe
cohen ou d'un autre type un journaliste
du canard enchaîné qui s'appelle nicolas
beau qui est un mauvais journaliste d'où
le nom ouais d'où le nom seulement
et en effet il ya un sentiment bizarre
se sentir épié se sentir avec en plus
chez ce genre de biographe qui sont qui
sont moins des écrivains et que des
encore une fois que des clones mentalité
de flics c'est vraiment poète vos
papiers
la phrase d'aragon écrivain vos papiers
il ya une sorte de manille
donner un sens à tous une folie du 100 m
alors à 22 ans vous avez fait ceci mais
alors ça explique cela est une espèce de
déluge d'interprétation au paranoïaque
qui sont totalement absurde
il ya ya ya deux manières de traiter ce
genre de livre le débat d'idées pas de
problème ma personne
pas de problème non plus en revanche les
proches et notamment les disparus ceux
qui ne sont plus là pour répliquer
eux-mêmes qu'il aurait peut être fait
avec plus de vigueur que je ne le ferai
moi-même ça c'est vrai que je prends je
prendrai très mal voir viennent y
toucher et que là je ne réagirai pas
comme covent garden mais comme un bon
écrivain tout le monde va dire de la
liberté d'expression tous azimuts il ya
des choses que je ne supporterais pas
que l'on aborde en tous les cas il ya un
livre autour de vous qui a très bien
marché c'est le livre de justine votre
fille
je suis très très fier delà du succès
littéraire de mes filles un succès
littéraire c'est un c'est un véritable
écrivain et et c'est pas fréquent vous
savez pour un bon moi je suis un père et
un père très très aisément de ma fille
et puis je suis aussi un écrivain et
c'est pas souvent dans l'histoire de la
littérature
un père et un fils ou un père et une
fille écrivains samar lui élections
demain entre armand et alexandre dumas
oui il ya quelques cas là vous êtes bon
ouais j'ai été adoubé par la chaîne bien
leur en continu sur votre actualité aux
états unis vous sortez vos bouquins les
guerres oubliées daniel pearl qui est
publicité par le par le public ça se
passe très bien non oui ça se passe ça
se passe en effet très bien tout temps
avec le petit bémol tout de même qu'en
amérique les choses peuvent durer 5 5
secondes c'est à dire se passait très
bien
un moment et puis on peut être balayé
oublier quelques quelques mois ou
quelques c'est le pays d'andy warhol en
roll qui disait au 21ème siècle chacun
sera célèbre un quart d'heure chacun
aura son quart d'heure de célébrité
donc il ya en effet un petit quart
d'heure ou warholiens autour de mes
livres aujourd'hui aux etats-unis alors
dernière activité le cinéma non pas en
tant que réalisateur cette fois mais en
tant que producteur terre et sambre
d'atiq rahimi qui est présenté à cannes
au festival la semaine prochaine c'est
un 7-1 très batik rémy vous le
connaissez c'est un écrivain franco
afghan qui a publié un livre chez pel
qui s'appelait terre et cendres et qu'il
adapte alors c'est un tournage qui était
très compliqué je crois que c'est le
premier film tourné en afghanistan et
avec des acteurs afghans depuis le début
de la guerre soviétiques sert depuis le
début des années 80 ça fait 25 ans que
les acteurs afghans n'ont pas joué et
d'ailleurs atiq rahimi me racontait que
dans les débuts du tournage il y avait
même comme une sorte de
et d'engourdissement des acteurs du film
c'était des acteurs c'était comme
l'homme à l'oreille cassée mois bull
l'homme qui a passé 50 ans dans les
glaces et bus qui ressort dans son
uniforme de grognards de landry et je
suis très très fier d'avoir aidé en
effet mon copain atiq rahimi à produire
ce film est très heureux qu'ils soient à
4 dans quelques jours il il a raison il
fait froid que je sens qu'elle a qu'à la
très froid je demande qu'on arrête l'air
conditionné
est-ce qu'on peut arrêter l'air
[Applaudissements]
c'est comme ça donne maintenant qu'on va
se faire souffler la faire non mais
c'est exactement
c'est ce que je viens au combat quand
j'ai vu comment elle le regarde et j'ai
compris qu'on voit là il est malin il
est forte et comment il a fait ça bord
est savoureux quand même un petit peu
agacé de te laisser le privilège
l'euro est ce que tu veux je n'ai pas
terminé est ce que tu peux déshabiller
francesca oui on retient tout alors je
fais pas loyal à emile la team il est
bien donc je disais que ce livre
récidive
montrez votre éclectisme enfin on
retrouve quand même votre ligne
directrice vos combats après le fascisme
et socialiste évidemment aujourd'hui
c'est le fondamentalisme incarné par le
séduisant tariq ramadan donc vous ne
vous rappelez quand même qu' il n'est
pas contre la lapidation des femmes
qu'ils demandent simplement un moratoire
c'est à dire une une suspension c'est
vrai qu'il est un des ténors de cet
islamisme en france et c'est vrai qu'on
a là un personnage qui vient la
télévision notamment ici d'ailleurs sur
ce plateau pour nous dire que
la lapidation des femmes les crimes
d'honneur au pakistan
ça pose éventuellement un problème qu'il
faut y mettre un moratoire il faut
interrompre sa pendant quelque temps le
temps de laisser les oulémas discuter
débattre et tranchées et qu'on verra
après si on les annuler si on les
supprime ou pas c'est une attitude qui
évidemment est inacceptable et et qui
participe de 7,7 corpus doctrinal qu'on
appelle en effet l'islamisme radical
ouais voilà qu'il faut pas l'inviter
tariq ramadan la télévision qu'il faut
les invités pour débattre je pense qu'il
faut l'éviter
je pense qu'il je pense d'abord qu'il
faut éviter tout le monde mais il faut
éviter ce genre de personnage en
essayant c'est ce qui s'est passé
d'ailleurs notamment ici en essayant de
2,2
de ne pas les traiter enfin de les
traiter pour ce qu'ils sont de leur
poser les bonnes questions de ne pas
donner le sentiment que cette opinion la
et l'opinion inverse serait d opinion
équivalente on peut pas laisser un type
dire par exemple je suis pour un
moratoire sur la lapidation
on peut pas laisser quelqu'un compter
les juifs qui ont eu à dire comme si
c'était d'un propos normal que les
invités oui marquer le coup lorsque
quelque chose d'inacceptable se dit je
crois que c'est le rôle d'aider des gens
de télévision comme vous alors la vraie
question évidemment il faut combattre
ici chez nous ce genre de propos ce
genre d'attitude
l'autre question si savoir si nous on
doit exporter nos conceptions à nous
c'est à dire faut-il faire la guerre
pour exporter des droits de l'homme
faut-il aller en irak pour imposer la
démocratie sur l'histoire irakienne
moi j'ai été très clair depuis le
premier jour et même avant le premier
jour d'aidé l'époque du débat sur
l'opportunité de guerre j'étais contre
je pensais que c'était une folie je
pensais qu'elle était mal préparée je
pensais qu'on avait à faire en amérique
à un gouvernement il ya une maison
blanche peuplé d'ignorants qui n'avait
aucune idée de cette région et de ses
enjeux
donc je pense que cette guerre a été
gelée dit dès le premier jour et hélas
ça se vérifie jour après jour un
désastre alors maintenant est ce que ça
veut dire pour autant que les lumières
la démocratie les droits de l'homme
soient réservés à une partie du monde
est interdite à une autre partie du
monde évidemment non mais si c'est la
vraie question pourquoi notre pourquoi
notre universalisme serait-il universel
qu'est ce qui fait que je parce que je
crois parce que je crois qu'une femme
irakienne a le droit comme une femme
italienne où une femme française de ne
pas être lapidée parce que je crois
qu'une femme nigériane a le droit de ne
pas être excisées parce que je crois que
les femmes pakistanaises que j'ai
rencontré à karachi et qui se fondent
brûlée vive par leurs maris qui veulent
simplement se débarrasser d'elle sous
prétexte qu'elles ont levé les yeux
sur un trône elles sont comme nos femmes
mais comme les femmes françaises elles
ont autant le droit que les femmes
occidentales à l'intégrité de leur corps
et à la justice
donc cette université cette universalité
là arrêtons avec le coupage des cheveux
en quatre arrêtons avec ce genre de
radio 6 nations évidemment qu'elle vaut
évidemment que l'universalité du droit
l'égalité décor le droit pour un corps
de ne pas souffrir de ne pas être
martyrisé il est universel si on suit
votre raisonnement se dire qu'il faut
aller faire la guerre à tous les gens
qui l'habitent des femmes à ce moment là
je pense pas qu'il faille leur faire la
guerre mais je pense qu'il y a d'abord
ya des circonstances il y en avait une
en tout cas et récidivant porte la trace
puisqu'une grosse partie du livre est
consacrée à sakété l'histoire de la
bosnie ben oui oui quand on a en effet
sous nos yeux au coeur de l'europe une
population une ville en l'occurrence
d'ailleurs musulmane dans sa majorité
qui se fait massacrer bombardé où on
sniffe les mômes au fusil à lunette
évidemment qu'il faut intervenir
aujourd'hui le monde occidental
fonctionne et ça c'est un des thèmes du
livre et c'est une des choses qui me
scandalise aujourd'hui comme s'il y
avait deux humanités absolument
disjointes l'une de l'eau une humanité
qui est dans l'histoire universelle et
une humanité qui a lâché l'accord de
l'histoire et qu'on peut laisser crever
dans ces marécages une humanité qu on
aurait vous savez on a fermé la porte et
je dis à la clé ça c'est la moitié de la
planète
c'est notamment notamment l'afrique est
certaine zone asiatique etc
et ça c'est inacceptable on ne peut pas
si on croit un tout petit peu aux
valeurs qui sont supposés fonder nos
sociétés et valeurs démocratiques
notamment
on ne peut pas accepter sur le tissage
là si on décide d'exporter les droits de
l'homme notre universalisme à nous c'est
la colonisation c'est ce qu'on a fait au
19ème siècle au début du xxème ça c'est
votre grand ça c'est votre grande adage
c'était ça jules ferry c'est ce qu'ils
voulaient faire justement je ne crois
pas en bosnie non c'est à dire
malheureusement les colonisateurs ils
ont pu ils prétendent exporter les
droits de l'homme et puis ils ont
exporté le racisme les coups de pied au
cul c'est ce que font les américains en
irak c'est ce que font aujourd'hui
américain en irak est pire ces images
que nous venons donc que nous venons de
recevoir et que la presse américaine a
publié ses vrais sons des images atroces
mais il ya une autre
il ya une autre manière de faire quand
on est intervenue en bosnie canton à
arrêter le massacre
perpétré par les milices serbes à
sarajevo on n'a pas colonisé la bosnie
alors il ya un texte très étonnant dans
récidive un texte que je ne connaissais
pas ce votre judéité bernard henri lévy
vite qu'apprennent nazisme pour beaucoup
de juifs le judaïsme était considérée
comme une malédiction il c'était le cas
de votre père par exemple pour qui le
peuple juif n'avait plus d'avenir il ya
plus de problème juif et vous il a fallu
vous attendiez 30 ans pour prendre
conscience de votre judéité jusque là
c'était dans une espèce de vide
finalement oui je crois qu'il y a eu
toute une génération de jeunes juifs qui
sont sortis de la seconde guerre
mondiale deux sets de 7 nuits de
l'europe qui avait été le nazisme avec
l'idée certainement pas de la honte
juive de soi bien sûr que non sûrement
pas de la dénégation
mais en tout cas que cette histoire là
l'histoire du judaïsme n'était était
porteuse de beaucoup plus de malheurs
que de grandeur et de bonheur est en
effet j'ai été élevé dans une famille où
c'était probablement où c'était l'idée
l'idée qui régnait je ne suis pas entré
dans une synagogue avant avant l'âge de
30 ans je n'avais aucune espèce d'idée
des textes juifs jusqu'à jusqu'à 30 ans
et comment vous êtes revenu à ça alors
c'est ce que je raconte en effet dans ce
dans ce texte qui s'appelle comment je
suis genève que j'ai écrit dans une
sorte de dialogue fraternel et et
véhément avec un ami disparu qui
s'appelle benny lévy qui venait de
l'extrême gauche qui venait de l'extrême
gauche qui avait été le secrétaire de
sartre qui a été l'un des personnages
qui m'a le plus impressionné dans ma vie
je ne crois pas être le seul c'est pour
moi
l'inde est l'un des rois secret de ma
génération et c'était qu'il a été écrit
en coloc avec lui beaucoup enfin en
débat et je raconte en effet dans ce
texte comment c'est une une aventure
philosophique que celle de mon retour au
judaïsme
il ya des gens qui reviennent au
judaïsme parce que comme comme maurice
clavel au christianisme issue cogne sur
leurs meubles avaient ils ont une ni
pascalienne son illumination donc il ya
des histoires de ce genre qui sont des
histoires mystique et spirituelle la
mienne est une aventure philosophique c
vraiment dans le dans le fil de ma de ma
réflexion sur le totalitarisme sur ces
questions vous abordiez tout à l'heure
les fascismes du xxème siècle que cette
ce retour aux textes juifs s'est imposée
à moi comme une espèce de nécessité
absolue sans laquelle je n'arrivais plus
à penser alors sur israël vous avez une
position très très mesuré très très
calme où vous êtes pour ce que vous
appelez la paix sèche c'est à dire deux
états qui sont pas obligé de s'aimer au
départ mais qui finiront peut-être par
s'aimer un jour vous êtes très déçu
parce que vous voyez au moyen-orient en
ce moment non depuis que j'entends
parler de tout ça depuis 30 ans l'idc
on va on va se rapprocher apprendre à se
connaître apprendre à s'aimer
et puis petit pas après petits pas on va
finir par faire la paix et puis il ya
toujours d'autres sur le chemin il ya
toujours un accident il ya toujours un
terrible attentat il ya toujours un
masque ou autre qui fait que ça ne
marche pas et que ça ne va pas ou donc
moi je suis partisan d'inverser
totalement les choses et de dire on fait
la paix d'abord et on fera l'amour après
on fait la paix d'abord on fait l'amour
après on fait le contrat d'abord on se
sépare et puis le temps passant et
peut-être plus vite qu'on ne croit
d'ailleurs les peuples apprendront à se
connaître à cb alors quand en échange de
l'évacuation de gaza ariel sharon en
profite quand même pour avancer un petit
peu en territoire palestinien
grâce aux nouvelles colonies vous
réagissez comme en moi je réagis d'abord
écouté avec un petit soupir de
soulagement à l'idée qu'enfin la droite
israélienne pao d'évacuer gaza déjà
c'est un petit pas ça suffit pas si
c'est pour gagner le temps d attente
attendait pour l'instant il ya quelques
semaines on nous on nous disait que gaza
était intangible
on nous disait que ça faisait partie du
grand israël enfin je me suis même
demandé si j'entendais bien enfin nous
avons un premier ministre israélien de
droite qui a brisé le tabou et qui a dit
on va sortir de gaza
c'est déjà un progrès alors ça suffit
pas moi je suis partisan d'un état
palestinien viable
1 parce que les palestiniens y ont droit
et deux parce que je crois que c'est la
seule garantie de sécurité pour israël
et que tant qu'il y'aura pas ça il y
aura 7 et cette situation de 2,2 de
pourrissement qu'est la situation
d'aujourd'hui est ce que vous seriez
d'accord dans l'idée d'une paix sèche
comme ça d'abord on commence par faire
la paix pour que les casques bleus
interviennent en israël et en palestine
j'en sais rien pour l'instant je crois
pas mais pourquoi on n'en parle jamais
de cette solution on en parle bien sûr
c'est une des hypothèses qui est
envisagée
c'est une des hypothèses est mauvais que
ce sens humiliant pour israël d'avoir
besoin des casques bleus bien sûr bien
sûr que ce serait humiliant pour israël
bien entendu mais la question n'est pas
là quand le mécanisme est enclenché
quand la d6 faire la paix est réel il
n'y a pas besoin si le bleu s'ils
avaient besoin de caisse que bleu vous
trouvez ça normal
on verra pour l'instant on n'y cela pour
l'instant mais non mais je trouverais ça
normal gens il faut voir dans quelles
conditions comment comme à chaque pas
sur quelles frontières comme un chypre
moi je pense que le jour où c'est ce que
j'appelle la paix sèche sera opéré le
jour où un gouvernement israélien
courageux dirhams attend ça y est on
arrête on crée une frontière ont fait
entériner cette frontière par la
communauté internationale que cette
conférence entrée de frontières dessine
un état palestinien viable
vous verrez comment d'un seul coup ça
sera comme une espèce de d'éclaircies
général moi je vous fais le pari que le
jour où des dirigeants courageux se
lèveront dans les deux camps ça sera
terminé il y aura pas besoin de casques
bleus ni de médiation internationale
inch'allah alors vos reportages vous
amène souvent dans les endroits les plus
dangereux de la planète c'est ce qu'on
lit en tous les cas quand on lit les
guerres oubliées même certains passages
de récidive
vous avez peur de mourir j'ai peur de
mourir
comme chacun j'ai bien sûr peur de
mourir mais il m'arrive
oui quand je me trouve quand je me
trouve au nigeria dans certaines des
scènes que je rapporte dans livres ou
quand je me trouve au burundi dont nous
parlions tout à l'heure il m'arrive
comme tous les reporter de guerre comme
tous ceux qui mettent leur vie un tout
petit peu en jeu pour rapporter avec les
dents un peu de vérité on a évidemment
parfois un peu peur de mourir bien sûr
on va vous faire une interview bernard
lévy si vous mourriez demain
[Musique]
ça c'est une nouveauté ça dans l'émotion
c'est une nouveauté
et si je suis attendu et si je suis
superstitieux si vous êtes superstitieux
vous pour quitter le plateau
immédiatement je ne veux pas trop
intelligent pour être ouverte et le
saviez vous oui qu'est ce que vous
voudriez absolument faire ce soir si
vous deviez mourir demain de la même
chose que tous les jours la poursuite d
habitude ce le miracle d'un jour de plus
et un change et surtout ne rien changer
dans les bras de qui aimeriez-vous
passer cette dernière nuit comme toutes
les nuits précédant dans les bras de la
femme de ma vie qui aimeriez vous
entendre une dernière fois au téléphone
s'il est question terrible qui
j'aimerais entendre pour la dernière
fois au téléphone nous et avec ariel
mebazaa entendre que c'était pas de
marques à l'antenne vous êtes avec celle
l'année salle a été si souvent fait
qu'elle ait pas de votre niveau j'espère
qu'elle sera coupée au montage c'est pas
bon non pas par total à rien si on plaît
rien ne peut le faire chier je vais pas
la couper au montage par nab août déjà
c'était 2010 sur l'or c'est la guerre
que tu veux battre coiffer
téléphone je dirais à un ancien ami avec
lequel je me suis débrouillé petit
souvent à temps voilà et avec lequel
j'aurai sûrement le désir de ses biens
de dissiper un malentendu puisque
souvent les brouilles sur des brouilles
de malentendus est-ce que vous
essaieriez décrire la dépêche
pour la presse la dépêche afp là vous
êtes naïf mon cher thierry ardisson
parce que la dépêche elle est pour
chacun d'entre nous d'ailleurs est déjà
écrite pour ornella mutti pour tirer là
disons même pour ma fille elle est déjà
écrite ce qu'on appelle dans les
journaux et dans les rédactions la
viande froide alors vous aimeriez qu'on
dise quoi de vous j'en ai télévisée
demain soir le compagnon d'arielle
dombasle s'est éteint ce matin ça déjà
c'est pas mal mais si j'ai droit encore
un tout petit temps d'antenne japan
today j'aimerais oui bien sûr et puis
j'aimerais nom qu on énumère peut-être
le titre de mes livres
si le journaliste en or pas comme quand
on compte les moutons ce réseau cible
aussi vous aimeriez un hommage de la
part de cuir cimetière parce que nous
estimons excusez moi demain c'est bon
j'ai lu dans récidive quelques discours
vous avez fait dans des cimetières
j'espère mourir avant vous vous ferez de
mire c'est d'accord
au moins ça va me viendra pas du tout
rire leçon devant clermont
je voudrais dire des vannes mois s'il
fait le jeu pourrait revenir pour
l'oraison funèbre d'abord le renommage
par qui sérieux non s'il n'était pas
s'ils n'étaient pas partis avant moi
donc dans l'hypothèse où j'aurai
peut-être demander à benny lévy ou alors
autre hypothèse il ya deux villes où on
m'aime bien il y à sarajevo où comme une
et mes initiales bhl veux le dire bosnie
herzégovine libre et puis à jérusalem
j'aurais bien vu de petite veillée
funèbre comme ça à quelques papas
beaucoup de monde mais quelques quelques
personnes quelques secondes de silence
chip sarajevo ou pas forcément centrale
pas les personnages de sanaa sara lee
les bruits des vieux copains à jérusalem
commencé et quelques secondes de silence
dans les deux cas vous ne liriez quel
livre si vous mourriez demain peut-être
une notice le journal du lendemain le
journal du lendemain de ma mort parole
réponse énigmatique oui je sais pas je
me suis dit [ __ ] et moi comme ya plein
de bouquins dont je connais pas je vais
fermer ma gueule vous reverrez quel film
à part le mien bien sûr et le tiens je
vais commencer par le sien et du corps à
l'hypothèse qu'il est correct 13e vous
encore une fois que vous envisagez que
je imaginer je crois je me mettrais
devant la télévision jose après comme un
fou toute la nuit tous les films que
tous les thèmes illustrés sur canal 21
et j'enverrai un paquet vous et
couturiers quelle musique musique
musique du jour c'est à dire si c'est le
matin les bruits de la ville si c'est la
nuit vous n'êtes pas très musique elle
s'en plaignait bernard n'a pas pouvoir
écouter de la musique à la maison ça lui
manque
elle nous l'a dit de mon vivant les nuba
qui est fait en boîte depuis que tu es
décédé
comment elle s'éclate ça ça m'énerve
elle revit un joli elle revient vous
trouveriez ça injuste de partir si tôt
samia il y avait un moment merveilleux
je crois que c'est de maurice ronet dans
feu follet qui disait un type comme moi
ne devrait jamais mourir et c'est
tellement vrai un type comme comme nous
comme nous devrait jamais mourir
est-ce que vous accepteriez de donner
certains de vos organes certaine les
organes vivre là je pensais pas tout de
suite au sexe je pense qu'il a voulu
garder s'il n'a jamais si des fois il ya
un type à la résurrection des corps si
elle existait ciel survie je donnerai
plus tôt plutôt mon âme
ça me semble mais sinon vous donnez rien
pas de rang il faut qu ils provoquent
des trains vers la gauche mise blanche
voudriez qu'on en fasse quoi de votre
collection de chemises blanches voir
c'est quoi ton vous me répondez d'abord
sur la collection de tee shirt noir et
je vous répondrai sur la collection de
chemises blanches
moi je l'aiderai ce que vous en faites
si moi je les donne à emmaüs mais il
aimait jamais l'abbé pierre et c'est
quoi ce blanc alors le secret de ce
blanc vos questions de ce fait ces
blancs et comment tu fais pour ça capte
les cheveux vous le saurez pas ce que tu
as encore beaucoup de cheveux oui c'est
vrai ça c'est leur côté un fixateur
comment tu t'organises
un fixateur matin et soir avec un
acharnement terrible je passe ma vie à
ça mais j'écris à peine le fixer mais
dernière chose est ce que vous penseriez
avoir eu une belle vie
écoutez je crois que je dirais vous
savez c'est le dernier mot de ces le
dernier mot de romain gary qui est un
autre écrivain que j'ai un peu connu et
que j'ai beaucoup aimé et dans son
dernier livre qui s'appelle vie et mort
d'emile ajar
il a ce moment extraordinaire c'est les
derniers à c'est la dernière phrase du
livre je me suis beaucoup amusé au
revoir et merci à thiais et mais l'aja
c'est publié chez grasset
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir bernard
soir on vous a mis entre hans et sophie
comme ça pour éviter tout régime a
ranimé le jeu voilà
ouais il n'y a pas eu pugilat normes
elles se détestent c'est que ça soit
senti qu'il y avait un vrai débat là il
y avait tellement les bouffées ensemble
impressionnant vont s'échanger des infos
de première bourre
je donnerai des infos qu'on le fasse à
un bouquin bien alors bernard on vous
appelle plus bhl mais beach elle
maintenant après votre succès américains
n'ont comme on dit là bas ils disent ben
ouais ouais c'est pas mal hein
or vous rentrez des usa ou votre dernier
livre american vertigo est sorti avant
la france
on y reviendra mais d'abord je voudrais
parler du livre american vertigo chez
grasset alors au départ c'est une
commande le grand magazine américain
atlantic monthly vous propose de refaire
cent soixante treize ans après le voyage
de lexie de tocqueville en amérique et
de publier le récit en feuilleton l'idée
d'aller juger sur pièce les clichés
véhiculés par l'anti américanisme
européen vous séduit et vous voilà parti
oui alors l'antiaméricanisme il faut
s'entendre ça veut pas dire bien sûr là
la critique de bouche ou la critique la
politique américaine
bush gelé vue pour ce livre d'assez près
je les observais et je suis plus sévère
que beaucoup d'anti américains mais en
revanche l'attitude qui consiste à dire
que les américains sont des crétins que
c'est tous des fondamentalistes
religieux à peine différent de ben laden
et des terroristes et que tous les maux
de la planète viennent de l'amérique ça
ça s'appelle l'anti américanisme et ça
c'est une espèce de virus planétaire qui
fait d'ailleurs que les uns et les
autres se défausse souvent de leurs
propres responsabilités dans les
problèmes qu'ils ont et ça je crois que
cet anti américanisme c'est bien pour
les peuples de le combattre et comment
le combattre
comment est-ce qu'on combat un fantasme
on a alors étudié par le voilà alors
vous prenez la route 25 mille kilomètres
en neuf mois vous dites c'est la route
qui fait le livre alors vous citez on
the road de jack kerouac enfin vous
faites pas là où ton beatnik vous l'a
fait avec un chauffeur voiles affalées
je la fais avec un copain
qui sait conduire et moi j'ai deux
problèmes dans ce voyage premièrement
j'ai pas le permis et deuxièmement quand
je voyage j'aime regarder et j'aime
prendre des notes et je crois que quand
on conduit on voit moins les choses et
on peut pas écrire j'ai passé 25 mille
kilomètres en effet à regarder et à
écrire ses parents ce top quoi c'est pas
en stop non c'est vrai c'est vrai enfin
c'est déjà pas en avion c'est déjà pas
mal et beaucoup de voyages aux états
unis qui se font en avion voilà c'est un
road book ou american vertigo on va
inventer ce concept ce soir à la re
départ
vous êtes au moins affiliées à la
tocqueville dans le voyage était motivée
par l'étude du système pénitentiaire
américain vous commencez votre périple
par la visite de la prison de new york
rikers island vous voyez ans dans ces
prisons américaines des hommes aux pieds
entravés un homme menotté avec des gants
sur les menottes parce que il avait
tenté d'égorger un gardien avec des
lamas rasoir qu'il avait cachée dans son
cul des regard de fauve enfin c'est un
peu ce que me disait christophe
rocancourt ya quinze jours sur ce
plateau c'est à dire c'est vraiment une
autre humanité dans ces prisons quoi ça
vous fait plaisir à ça dix ans à lantier
américain qui surveille on vous vend
cher thierry ardisson il ya un peu de ça
c'est vrai que les prisons américaines
c'est là c'est vraiment la face sombre
c'est une des façons pour ce n'est pas
la seule de ce pays et c'est vrai que il
ya une tendance aux états unis à
considérer les prisons pas seulement
comme un lieu de punition
pas seulement comme un lieu
éventuellement de réhabilitation qui
préparait à une réinsertion
mais comme un lieu d'exclusion c'est à
dire une sorte de partage en train entre
un monde qui est le monde des vivants
normaux et puis ce monde-là des demies
vivant par exemple riker's island ça
c'est vrai je vais encore vous faire
vous faire trop plaisir là m'énerve
méricain thaïlande c'est vrai que c'est
la prison de new york et elle a été
construite sur un ancien dépôt d'ordures
c'est à dire c'était la décharge
publique de new york là où la ville
pendant d'aider des décennies à déverser
ses poubelles à cet endroit là on
déverse aujourd'hui les poubelles de la
société c'est-à-dire les délinquants
alors ça c'est vrai que c'est pas le bon
connaît de ce pays
alors ensuite fait une halte dans une
ville qui s'appelle dearborn
c'est une ville à forte communauté arabe
où les leaders avoue s'inspirer du lobby
juif
ils vous disent on a 50 ans de retard
mais un jour on sera leur ego alors ce
qui vous surprend là dedans c'est
finalement les juifs ne sont pas pour
pour ces arabes là des ennemis mais des
modèles d'une certaine façon à 7 à côté
de détroit
c'est une ville en effet c'est une ville
arabe dont les 80 % des habitants sont
d'origine arabe sont des musulmans pieux
les mcdonald's
il ya une pancarte qui précise qu'ils
sont halal est ce que je trouve
formidable et évidemment géant en tête
comme pendant tout ce voyage des
questions françaises parce que j'ai
passé un an aux états unis bien sûr
aussi pour m'interroger sur nous sur le
pays à nous sur notre sur nos problèmes
d'immigration sur le racisme en france
sur nos banlieues
il ya deux choses qui me surprennent la
première c'est que ces arabes militants
sont des patriotes américains c'est à
dire que la chimie entre les deux
fonctionnent bien
il ya une espèce de dialectique
mystérieuse enfin j'essaye un peu de
percer le mystère qui fait que ce n'est
pas contradictoire
il n'y a pas pas question de confier le
drapeau pas question de siffler l'hymne
national ô à l'équivalent du stade de
france
et la deuxième chose en effet je leur
dis qui je suis le seul faiza mais il
est en train de mon nom ils savent que
je suis juif je leur dis que je suis non
seulement juifs mais que j'ai un lien
très fort et personnel à l'état d'israël
et à l'horizon cette réponse
extraordinaire ils disent d'écouté on
n'a aucun problème avec ça au contraire
pour nous l'itinéraire laventure des
juifs en amérique c'est pas du tout
notre repoussoir c'est notre rêve c'est
notre c'est notre modèle notre american
dream
c'est là l'expérience des galets la
communauté juive
en revanche dans une réserve de pine
ridge vous rencontrez un leader indien
qui vit dans une roulotte dans un
terrain vague
et lui il est absolument antisémite
norio sémites marty il vous dit vous ici
monsieur lévy vous n'êtes pas encore en
israël
vous aimez les sharon a demandé aux
juifs de france des millions en israël
comment ça se fait que vous ne soyez pas
et vous explique qu'il n'a pas été
départ par les juifs de cleveland qui
est la ville voisine et que finalement
ils les gifles ont abandonné en effet
d'abord c'est un personnage que je suis
très ému de rencontrer ses parents
céline c'est une c'est un vétéran de la
bataille de wood gundy il ya il ya vingt
ans c'est une grande personnalité de la
cause indienne et moi je je je me sens
évidemment très requis très mobilisés
par sept par cette souffrance alliel je
suis de ceux qui croient que l'amérique
s'est construite aussi sur ce crime là
ce crime fait aux indiens et donc je
viens vraiment dans cet état d'esprit
est là je découvre une chose et là
encore c'est une affaire française
aussi je découvre une chose qui me qui
me sidère en fac on connaît un peu
qui et comment appeler ça la rivalité
des victimes
la guerre des mémoires la compétition
des mémoires sept indiens là il me dit
une chose qu'on entend en france souvent
que tu donnais aurait pu démarrer
oui gros trous tariq ramadan qui
consiste à dire en gros que l'on peut
pas compter jusqu'à 2 que si on s'occupe
de la de la mémoire juive
ça veut dire qu'on se moque de la
mémoire indienne que si on pense à la
shoah ça veut dire qu'on s'intéresse pas
à la traite des à la traite des noirs
autrement dit je rencontre un homme et
ça c'est une grande leçon pour la france
aussi qui pensent que que la souffrance
c'est comme des parts de marché payés
que ceux qu'on donne aux 1 on peut pas
le donner à l'autre avec sept indiens et
des représentatifs de ces le
porte-parole de deux ans toutes nos
sessions bien sûr que non non il
n'engage que lui c'est juste un
l'indien antisémites ont aidé pas
emblématique d'une qui n'engage que lui
mais il engage laurent baffie il il
engage je crois cette cette monstruosité
contemporaine la guerre des mémoires se
[ __ ] ses mémoires à la figure mais
pour faire quoi lui donner autant
d'importance c'est parce qu'il y en a
beaucoup et parce qu'il y en a par
exemple aussi alors si vous voulez qu'on
mettre les pieds dans le plat il y en a
aussi chez les noirs quelqu'un comme
farrakhan les gens de nichane of islam
ces gens d'islam berg que j'étais allé
voir à l'époque de mon enquête sur
daniel pearl et équipe ans alors c'est
pas des noirs cdc des musulmans
d'origine arabe alors celle inverse du
modèle de dearborn dont je parlais tout
à l'heure c'est des gens qui disent vous
nous gonfler avec notre show temps
comparé à celle là choix on s'occupera
pas les palestiniens donc ça représente
c'est pour ça que je vais donner enfin
c'est pas livre ces quatre pages dans
l'ue ça représente une une idéologie
contemporaine d'une très grande
perversité dont je n'imaginais pas moi
il ya 20 ans à l'époque où on fonde et
sos racisme
à l'époque où ont défilé dans les rues
de toulon ou dans les rues déjà de
vitrolles en disant juifs arabes c'est
toujours de coop nos potes qu'on
assassine j'imaginé pas que ça puisse
venir
or c'est là c'est aux états unis c'est
en france et là pour le coup les états
unis c'est un peu la matrice c'est un
peu le modèle et ça permet de voir ce
qui est en train d'arriver et j'espère
pas de déferler bien alors ensuite los
angeles et las à los angeles c'est
beaucoup plus sympathique jeu là
beverley hills vous rencontrer sharon
stone et là vous êtes épaté vous
connaissez quand même des gens riches et
célèbres de par le monde et quand vous
arrivez chez sound stone c'est un peu
petit garçon qui arrive chez sound stone
s'est pas petit garçon ces jeux je suis
épaté parce que je la trouve très
intelligente très hâte et listrac ça
surprend et parce qu'il me c'est
toujours une surprise de rencontrer
quelqu'un de très intelligent entend
déjà été fait et pas seulement par
sharon stone j'ai été épaté par warren
beatty bien sûr que j'ai trouvé aussi
extrêmement brillant et sharon stone ce
qui m'épate c'est qu'elle me fait sur un
personnage auquel je m'intéresse déjà
depuis quelques mois
à ce moment du livre quel personnage de
george bush
elle me fait une analyse que je trouve
d'une très grande lucidité d'une très
grande pertinence
elle vous raconte l'histoire d'un soldat
qui a jamais voulu être soldat mais qui
est issu d'une famille de soldats et
c'est un peu comme boucher elles se
demandent peut-être qu'il n'a jamais
voulu être président voilà et que c'est
pour plaire à papa c'est pour plaire à
maman et que c'est pour plaire à bobonne
qu'il a voulu être président et elle le
met dans la situation d'une là encore
d'une sorte de deux enfants humiliés
bernanos rien reprenant sa revanche sous
le poids d'une espèce ddip en béton qui
lui poserait dessus et qui expliquerait
beaubien de ces de ses actions depuis
donc c'est ça qui m'épate chez charles
c'est un peu la simone signoret des
américains n'auraient manqué carrément
pas cette image d'intellectuel ici un
nom mais elle a une image de sans
culotte mais pas te las vegas alors là
c'est déjà plus rigolo c'est dans des
clubs de la dancing c'est là où les
fifres et leurs seins et leurs sexes
mais on n'a pas droit touché évidemment
on connaît ça ici aussi et vous évoquez
la misère érotique du milieu puritains
l'america deux démons le sexe et le
refoulement du sexe c'est à dire le
puritanisme et c'est probablement
d'ailleurs là aussi je vais vous faire
plaisir mais pas trop c'est probablement
le seul point commun le seul point
commun entre le fondamentalisme
américain et l'autre fondamental il
cette espèce de lien un pervers entre
entre le sexe et son refoulement et le
lap dancing alors en effet dans ce club
de las vegas ces filles robotisée clown
et qui pratique avec un art
extraordinaire là la création du désir
et sa frustration en même temps c'est
exactement ça c'est c'est le sexe en
régime puritains appareil faisait dans
un bordel dans d'être valais c'est bien
documenté
il a bossé là je vous parlais 7 juillet
la philosophe de terrain s'en vient le
terrain c'est à deux envie d'écrire en
tout cas lisez déjà le bordel c'est le 7
sec salariés des panneaux sur le lit
avec les résultats des tests vénérien
test de séropositivité il ya des caméras
pour pas que la fille soit violente et
enfin pour la surveiller en tous les cas
il ya un truc extraordinaire c'est qu'il
ya dans les bars des américains il ya
des pentes aménagée pour les handicapés
voilà c'est bien ça n'aurait dirait pas
le contraire c'est ça des effets et
faire du politiquement correct
égalité absolue à la dic ap je crois que
non mais vous blaguez un handicapé a le
droit comme tout à fait d'aller au
bordel
en effet un espèce de passage à côté de
l'escaladé dans la descente
[Rires]
y'a pas de barbe est là bas non
seulement les débordements plus et
dépendre du capital il ya un truc pour
les cartes de crédit il ya une machine à
terme on peut retirer du cash
il ya des cartes de visite avec
l'adresse internet il ya le bill of
rights sur la table de nuit à gauche il
ya le drapeau américain sur labrador
pour les aveugles
c'est après à sun city alors ça c'est
une ville pour les retraités qui est
coupé du reste du monde par un par un
mur alors évidemment on sait très
inquiétants parce que d'abord vous avez
vraiment pris tous les passages quoi
vous êtes vraiment le roi des salles ou
non mais les passages un peu qui
pourrait alimenter l'entière d'habitude
et c'est vrai c'est son truc c'est
l'inventeur de cette ville scène city
c'est le même qui a travaillé sur les
camps d'internement pour les japonais
donc c'est assez ça fait froid dans le
dos ça fait froid dans le dos mais je ne
commenterai pas cet exemple-là jour de
compass a des choses plus sympathique
pour les amis revenons aux [ __ ]
[Rires]
alors vous rencontrer aussi les
néoconservateurs et sharp earl
alors là vous êtes très ambivalents
disons si non ambiguë sur l'eau sur eux
vous êtes contre l'esprit munichois et
vous êtes pour le renversement de saddam
hussein ça va vous êtes d'accord
et puis quand le type vous dis que
finalement savoir s'ils avaient ou pas
des armes de destruction massive en irak
c'est pas très important
là vous sentez très loin de lui sur les
néoconservateurs j'essaye surtout d'être
d'être honnête et d'être b est de
montrer que c'est plus complexe qu'on ne
le croit en france je me rappelle
d'ailleurs et un autre personnage dans
le lire mais le pétrole c'est bill
kristol est venu si vous avez reçu 6 200
tr bien j'avais vu ça comme spectateur
et je ne souviens très bien de cette
émission je trouve que vous aviez été
très injuste avec lui et très
simplificateurs si vous permettez nous
serons prêts c'est vrai que ces types
il ya toute une partie de leur temps de
leur histoire qui est insupportable
leur façon qu'ils ont notamment tout
simplement d'endosser la politique de
bush le à z l'histoire de la guerre en
irak tout ça est insoutenable cette
guerre en irak est une tragédie une
horreur une absurdité très bien mais en
même temps il ya quelque chose dans
l'histoire de ces gens qui méritent le
respect si on est honnête je me souviens
ce bill kristol il décède il essayait de
dire ça face à je crois eric laurent
pillet river pas alors qu'est-ce qu'il
essayait de dire il essayait dire par
exemple que il est universaliste que
contre une tradition américaine qu'à la
tradition isolationniste qui pensent que
l'amérique a rien à [ __ ] de ce qui se
passe dans le reste du monde lui il
pense que l'amérique a des devoirs parce
qu'elle est puissante parce qu'elle est
parce qu'elle est riche qu'elle a des
devoirs vis-à-vis du reste du monde
deuxièmement il est anti relativiste
c'est des gens qui pensent que la
démocratie c'est pas seulement bon pour
les peuples blanc ou pour les peuples
occidentaux que la démocratie c'est bon
pour tout le monde qui a pas d'aidé des
fatalités culturel ou civilisationnel
qui pèserait sur certains peuples et qui
leur attire et d'y interdire et d'y
aller ce que je dis c'est ce que
j'essaie de dire parce qu'il ya en effet
il ya une partie du livre qui est une
discussion un peu haut
un peu au corps à corps avec avec ces
gens c'est qu'on peut pas les traiter
peut pas les diaboliser
on peut pas laisser agoniser on peut pas
dire on peut pas faire comme si comme on
l'a souvent lu dans les journaux c'est
lé lé prince des ténèbres huriez c'est
plus compliqué alors si des adversaires
mais que j'essaye de traiter loyalement
et mieux quand ils achètent bouche ils
achètent aussi la peine de
la loire tout le monde ça c'est trop
sexuel l'ordre moral le créationnisme et
c'est alors c'est ce que je dis alain
d'encre et moi si je quand je vais au
restaurant avec tel ou tel jeu prend pas
tout le menu je prends un plat vous
quand vous allez au resto avec bush vous
vous croyez obligé de prendre toute la
carte et vous allez crever d'une
indigestion alors vous avez à guantanamo
qui est donc une base américaine à cuba
qui est louée à cuba
c'est même une scène formidable c'est
une série de bandes dessinées chaque
année à la même date il ya le général en
chef de la base américaine qui prend son
qui prend son chèque sont des scores qui
se présentent à la guérite de la
frontière de l'autre côté il ya général
alcatraz du côté cubain qui arrive avec
la même escorte avec le machin il lui
donne le ch est le général cubain
téléphone alain van au leader massy
volume et ou à l'un de ses conseillers
et rituellement le conseiller de castro
lui dit chers amis la location par les
américains n'est pas reconnue vous
rendez cheikh immédiatement les deux à
se saluer ils s'en vont des deux c'est
une scène assez rigolote mais watan cela
dit c'est pas rigolo non c'est pas
rigolo raconter la base hors la base
américaine classique avec les villas
fitness-club nightclub enfin c'est assez
agréable et puis le camp et vous dites
au sujet du camp si ce sont des
terroristes pourquoi ya pas de procès et
si ce sont des prisonniers de guerre
pourquoi ils ne sont pas soumis à la
convention de genève
évidemment c'est c'est tout le problème
ça plus les tortures plus ces espèces de
deux fonds procès auquel j'ai assisté et
qui s'appelle les a et b1 qui sont des
procès ou à la place des juges vous avez
des militaires à la place de l'avocat
vous avez un autre militaire et à la
place du traducteur vous avez un
quatrième militaire c'est évidemment
scandaleux c'est pas à l'honneur de
l'amérique et je suis je plaide dans le
lit mais après y être allé et je
videmment je milite pour la fermeture de
guantanamo
mais mais mais thierry
ardisson ce que je crois aussi et ça je
le dis également c'est que là encore il
faut pas il faut pas dire n'importe quoi
une zone extraterritoriale avec des
procédures arbitraires avec des gens qui
n'ont pas de statut c'est pas le goulag
alors vous terminez votre bouquin sur
une réflexion au delà du voyage propre
grandi sur qu'est-ce qu'un américain
donc il ya un truc sont très
intéressants sur les musées tiens vous
dites qu'en fait ils mettent tous dans
les musées sans discernement fait oui je
sais ce que je dis oui c'est ça à ce que
je dis c'est que là encore contrairement
à l'idée qu'on a en tout cas moi que
j'avais et qu'on a ce je croise souvent
en france l'idée du pays neuf tourner
vers l'avenir avec des projets etc et
qui n'auraient pas de passé qui nous
rappelle mémoire qui serait indifférent
à sa mémoire
quand on regarde vraiment quand on fait
la route comme je les fait quand on fait
ces 20 minutes ses vingt cinq mille
kilomètres on s'aperçoit que c'est
exactement le contraire
le peuple américain est obsédé par le
passé il est envahi par sa mémoire ya
des musées des musées n'importe quoi des
musées du maïs des musées du kop cornes
des musées des pierres fossilisés des
musées des crotte de dinosaure des
musées de la pharmacie des ja même alors
un exemple qui m'a fait ça fait partie
des scènes
vraiment à tout cas qui me font rire
dans le libre jeu c'est précieux mais à
un moment donné
j'arrive dans un hôtel à des mauls en
plein milieu de la prairie américaine au
coeur de l'iowa et on me donne une
chambre et le réceptionniste très
fièrement me dit écoutez c'est pas
n'importe quelle chambre qu'on vous ait
donné la blessure lévy faut vous le
sachiez
c'est la chambre dans laquelle john
kerry va venir dans huit jours j'ai
écouté très honorable qui m'attendent et
ce n'est pas tout regardez r je vois il
y avait sous cellophane une assiette
avec du fromage du fromage sous
cellophane dit mais qu'est ce que c'est
ils disent c'est l'assiette de fromages
qui sera servi à john terry d'un bijou
et puis encadré au mur à une lettre
dactylographiée du service de presse de
john kerry qui est la demande de kerry
en matière de minibar alors de dai est
qu que le regular doritos des petites
pastilles valda etc et les deux choses
le cadre est l'assiette était déjà
muséifier les toits comme des traces
anticipé de ceux qui n'avaient pas
encore eu lieu mais qui était déjà
entrée dans la mémoire une espèce de une
espèce dans tes musée ouais alors ça
c'est vrai que c'est un truc américain
très étrange qui témoignent d'ailleurs
de cette espèce de vertige bertinerie
voilà quand on sait plus très bien qui
en est quand on cible très bien où on va
quand on est vulnérable comme sont les
américains parce qu'encore une fois
c'est une des choses qui m'a le plus
frappé bahia ce rapport un peu fou un
peu névrotique à sa propre à sa propre
histoire à sa propre et au palais de
l'obésité vous dites que l'obésité en
amérique l epa physique même pas
tellement physique bizarrement mais que
c'est surtout une obésité de tours est
quoi oui je dis que l'obésité c'est une
métaphore absolument que des corps
obèses là encore contrairement à ce que
disent les antiaméricains pas bleu visé
il y en a pas plus qu'en france il ya un
lobby de lentilles obésité qui essaie de
convaincre les américains qu'à 5 kg trop
ils sont déjà obèse ça c'est une autre
affaire mais jeudi par contre que il ya
obésité de tout le reste c'est à dire
les villes qui sont énormes les
aéroports qui sont gigantesques que les
les centres commerciaux qui ressemble à
les villes les églises qui ressemblent à
des à des stades de france les les
budget il ya une espèce de pertes comme
un code qui se serait déréglé là encore
le vertige américains comme une limite
qui serait au fond ce qui me frappe
aux etats unis c'est là le dérèglement
du rapport entre le entre la limite et
l'illimité
voila voila et puis vous terminez sur le
terrorisme évidemment avec la théorie de
fukuyama la fin de l'histoire
opposés généralement à celle de
huntington la guerre des civilisations
et voulait refusé toutes les deux
voulaient envoyer à dos toutes les deux
oui oui je crois en effet que c'est les
deux camps quand on regarde vraiment
l'amérique sait les deux grandes
idéologies qui domine le pays d'un côté
fukuyama qui dit enfin qu'il dit c'est
pas aussi ça bien sûr mais il se passera
plus rien le terrorisme c'est pas grand
chose c'est les dernières convulsions de
la bête et les dernières convulsions du
mal mais la démocratie est déjà en train
de digérer tout ça et puis de l'autre
côté hunting tonnes qui dit pas du tout
l'histoire au contraire est de retour et
elle est en train d'opposer bloc contre
bloc des grandes civilisations notamment
la civilisation de l'occident et la
civilisation de l'islam alors je crois
en effet qu'ils ont tous les deux en or
et c'est ça que j'essaie d'expliquer
dans cette petite discussion
philosophique avec l'un ni avec l'autre
je crois que fukuyama a tort parce que
il se passe au contraire des choses que
ce soit en inde que ce soit en chine et
que ce soit surtout du côté de l'islam
radical et ses contradictions là elles
sont elles sont fortes elles sont
peut-être même irréductible et je pense
que huntington a tout autant tort que
lui parce que là le vrai affrontement
c'est évidemment pas un affrontement
entre civilisations c'est évidemment pas
surtout pas le west comme il dit contre
le reste ça c'est une manière abominable
de voir les choses est ce que je lui
oppose
et c'est là dessus que se termine le
livre ce que je lui oppose c'est l'idée
que là la vraie guerre de civilisation
c'est la guerre entre la démocratie et
le fascisme partout guerre entre la
démocratie et le fascisme chez nous en
europe en france ô et aux états unis et
bières entre la démocratie et le
fascisme dans les pays musulmans entre
les démocrates les hommes des lumières
les laïcs les femmes qui se battent pour
la démocratie à l'intérieur de l'islam
et puis les les fondamentalistes et les
intégristes ce que nous disions il ya
quelques jours
avec sa dinde rushdie avec taslima
nasreen avec des intellectuels musulmans
dans le manifeste de charlie hebdo la
guerre de civilisation la seule qui
vaille c'est la guerre entre les entre
les fascistes et les démocrates
[Musique]
toulouse
messier
[Musique]
ce qui s'est passé bernard henri lévy
sait qu'après avoir fait les 25000 km
pour écrire le bouquin vous avez refait
une tournée des états unis pour le
lancer c'était un véritable boulot de
rockstar que vous avez fait là non
imboulou d'intellectuels vous avez fait
des conférences sold out aux quatre
coins du pays non mais sérieusement oui
oui bien sûr bien sûr c'est ce qu'on
appelle en amérique un bouc tour si tu
as c'est un pays tellement énorme lancer
un livre aux états unis le faire
connaître c'est comme si on lançait un
livre entre stockholm lisbonne belgrade
et landes reims et en même temps c'est
ça les états unis alors il ya eu des
bonnes et des mauvaises critiques les
bonnes critiques veut acheter une page
dans libération pour les pour les mettre
les mauvaises critiques étaient plutôt
dans le canard enchaîné
mais ce qui est très étonnant c'est
qu'ils avaient des journaux où il y
avait à la fois des bonnes et des
mauvaises critiques
oui ça a été un la bataille d'hernani
non ça a été un débat intellectuel et ça
a été un débat intellectuel c'est ça qui
est bon enfin moi c'est ça qui m'a fait
plaisir en tout cas et c'était et
c'était un peu le but c'est que en effet
les journaux par exemple se sont un peu
un peu divisé indiscuté à l'intérieur il
y avait un papier horrible qui
paraissait quelques jours après il y
avait un autre rédacteur ou à une autre
plume associé au journal qui faisait un
papier plutôt favorables ou très
favorables
berne en rêvez vous êtes un philosophe à
faire une interview penseurs
mais qu'est ce que c'est que nathalie
pensait hinata nous pensions c'est par
exemple de vous demander à quoi pense un
philosophe quand il vient à la
télévision a essayé d'abord ne pas se
faire trop piégée ouais
à quoi pense un philosophe quand ils
regardent la télévision qu'il ferait
mieux d'être en train d'écrire
à quoi pense un philosophe quand ils
pensent à arielle dombasle qu'il a bien
fait de la piéger la rencontre et de
l'épousé de l'élu
un copain ça philosophe quand une jeune
étudiante avec le ventre à l'air bien le
voir arielle dombasle la composent ce
philosophe quand il va dans un bar gay
arielle dombasle toujours savoir choses
là ça marche plus non il pense dans un
bar gay et il pense au gai savoir à quoi
pense le philosophe sur le bord de sa
piscine
un philosophe qui pense au principe
d'archimède oui ah oui un corps plongé
dans l'eau est un classique d'archivés
heureusement qu'on n'est pas tout le
temps fuit le savez là je réponds ça
philosophe quand on lui parle de dieu
ils pensent à l' homo fameux de stelios
qui que vous connaissez si dieu si du
est mort tout est permis et ils pensent
aussi d'ailleurs que ça marche à
l'envers que si dieu est trop vivant et
s'il est trop vive rendre à la tête des
gens tout est permis aux six et les
fanatics et les fondamentalistes et les
laits fascislamistes d'aujourd'hui à
quoi pense le philosophe en découvrant
le meurtre d'ilan halimi à la télévision
là ils pensent ils pensent pas tellement
là là il est là il est frappé de stupeur
d'abord est en tout cas en ce qui me
concerne la même stupeur que celle que
j'ai ressenti lorsque j'ai vu à la
télévision les premières images du
meurtre de daniel pearl
c'est à dire une stupeur 100 mo stupeur
absolue et là la pensée elle vient
derrière elle ya appris à quoi pense la
philosophe quand on demande à quoi il
sert c'est une bonne question
commence un philosophe quand on lui
demande comment être heureux qu'il ait
pas là pour ça et qu'il faut pas
confondre avec les les astrologues les
diététiciens les masseurs où les hommes
politiques
à quoi pense un philosophe pour les 30
ans des nouveaux philosophes ils pensent
à françoise verny à françoise verny cas
et et qui est morte aujourd'hui qui a
été une très grande éditrice et qui
était notamment l'éditrice des nouveaux
philosophes c'est à dire de d'andré
glucksmann de moi et de quelques
secondes elle compense un philosophe
quand il voit son compte en banque
il pense au mood françoise sagan que
j'ai toujours trouvé formidable sur
l'argent françoise sagan disait l'argent
bonvalet et mauvais m ouais voilà pense
à ça a commencé un philosophe quand il
paye ses impôts que c'est la moindre des
choses
à quoi pense un philosophe quand il fait
l'amour c'est la moindre des choses que
c'est la moindre des choses et il pense
aussi alors si les philosophes ils
pensent aux limites de l'amour
platonique très d'accord trait aux
limites extrêmes de la tête un copain
ans un philosophe devant la montée en
puissance de nicolas sarkozy dans le
pays
le philosophe qu'est ce qu'ils pensent
labre il espère que sarkozy a pas trop
la grosse tête parce que ces choses là
ça va ça vient que les vrais les vrais
intermittents du spectacle d'aujourd'hui
c'est quand même les hommes politiques
bien
[Applaudissements]
à quoi pense un philosophe quand
dieudonné c'est de l'empêcher de
s'exprimer à la halle philosophie vous
réponds que c'est très très difficile
d'empêcher un un philosophe en général
et celui lampard à quoi pense un
philosophe devant les caricatures de
mahomet ils pensent à une idée qui
étudient des magnifiques unes des idées
je crois les plus les plus importantes
qu'elle est produite l'humanité et qui
est d'ailleurs une idée un peu française
est un peu américaine et qui est l'idée
de laïcité face à l' affaire des
caricatures de mahomet il sort sa
laïcité
à quoi pense un philosophe dans la
guerre en irak il pense à vous fait que
vous faites
il pense à un philosophe que j'évoque
dans livre qui est un philosophe
américain qui s'appelle michael wolf
there qui est un philosophe ou dans
lequel je me reconnais beaucoup et qui
distinguait entre les guerres justes et
les guerres injustes et face à la guerre
en irak le philosophe d'aujourd'hui dit
qu'à une troisième catégorie c les
guerres absurdes
ouais qu'en pense un philosophe quand il
pense à la france
il rêve à l'europe à quoi pense un
philosophe quand il va recommencer les
guerres de religion il pense à montaigne
et voltaire à quoi pense un philosophe
quand il est aux toilettes qui est lent
chez ea
il pense à la question philosophique par
excellence avec eux en anglais il ya
cette scène là dans le camp je me fais
arrêter sur une autoroute en train de
pisser
to be or not to be this de quoi chauffer
bien voilà ce à quoi il pense à quoi
pense un philosophe dans un
embouteillage
un philosophe je ne sais pas mais moi je
penserai à à une très belle réplique de
fellini dans fellini rôdant roma ou
fellini disait la fin du monde
commencera par un embouteillage
à quoi pense un philosophe devant les
six biographie qui lui sont consacrés
écoutez il est flatté une seconde près
et puis après il se dit franchement
est-ce qu'il ya pas des sujets plus
intéressants que celui là est en tout
cas moi je pense qu'il ya tellement de
sujets importants aujourd'hui est ce que
ça vaut vraiment la peine de faire si
biographie sur le sur le philosophe
encaisse du c'est beaucoup si scott
brooks est énorme et je trouve que c'est
pas très utile un copain ça philosophe
dans la chute de villepin dans les
sondages il pense que c'est c'est le
moment de voir là pour lui et pour ceux
qui l'observent l'épaisseur de son cuir
dans la vie d'un homme politique et à ce
moment là qui est un moment capital il
on passe tous par là qui est l'épreuve
du feu comment ils sortent de l'épreuve
du feu c'est l'épreuve du feu de
villepin pas voilà comment comment il
résistera ça c'est une épreuve
initiatique pour un pour tous les hommes
politiques à commencer un philosophe en
se réveillant il pensa il lançait ce
qu'il a lu la veille
ouais à quoi pense un philosophe en se
couchant ça dépend s'il est seul ou s'il
est accompagné mon cher thierry ardisson
et s'il est celle ci les seuls il pense
à toutes les raisons qui l'auraient de
pas se coucher à compenser un philosophe
quand ils ne pensent à rien ils essayent
que ça se voit pas trop et pour être sûr
de ne rien rater de linda hardy tube
abonnez vous il m'était impossible ou